wrong button all right we'll open up the
public hearing on House Bill 1346 and
here from the prime sponsor represent
lean which I don't have a card
yet thank
you good morning represented lean
morning Mr chairman I do have a hand out
I guess I can give to representative
grass
so good morning for the record my name
is Peter Lehman I represent Hillsboro 33
which is Peterboro and
Sharon so this item deals with the
ability of um bed and breakfast to hand
out snacks and you'll see in the handout
that is coming
around the Food Service license for a
cranberry metal Farm which is located in
Peterboro and I was contacted last
year by the owner of cranberry Meadow
and they were quite concerned that they
could not even give out a cookie so I
have a bag full of cookies for the
committee
so I scheduled this so for those of you
who didn't have your proper breakfast
this
morning there better not be any nuts or
anything in that one's safe for you Mr
chairman but seriously uh well again on
a side it certainly doesn't violate any
ethical guidelines because it's the
cookies are worth less than $25 a piece
so I think we're all set there
um in
[Music]
Peterboro no
uh she can't make them legally and give
them out
so
um so anyway I um told her I'd take the
charge to see what we can do about this
because as the owner pointed out they
have guests arriving at all hours of the
afternoon Into the Night and most
restaurants in the petyo area close up
between 8 9 so if you have a guest
coming in at 10: or 9:00 she can't
legally give them a brownie or a
sandwich or anything else and it just
seems to me that why this is on the
books is I don't know but um to me it
made no sense in our state where we're
trying to improve tourism that we would
specifically prohibit as you'll see what
the permit conditions are no preps of
snacks lunch dinner or catering events
and again all she's looking for is the
ability to as the Bill calls for provide
such a license that shall permit snacks
and meals just for the patrons not
somebody coming in off the street but
people that are staying at the bed and
breakfast and with that Mr chairman I
think I'm
done well no you're
not
you called
me did you now I did and I guess I could
point out that you suggested a
compromise and of eight days or six days
to give out snacks I thought we should
just get rid of the provision Alto
together
okay any questions for the committee
members yes thanks for taking my
question so I guess I'm confused so I
assume that the these bed and breakfasts
have are their certified K kitchens for
for um serving yes because they serve
breakfast so so why is it even on the
books that they can't do snacks I have
no idea it doesn't make any sense to me
because I think I may have mentioned
this to your chairman if there was
concern about um the uh waste facilities
like a leech field or something uh they
could go to a restaurant that was open
and then come back and use the
facilities at the bed and breakfast so
cuz I had heard from somebody there was
some concern maybe it would T over tax
leech Fields but nobody really could
give me a specific answer why this is on
the books okay would you believe this
committee is familiar with this type of
issue we've had these bills over the
last couple years we've had this issue
and that is what we have
learned is that there is two kinds of
kitchens in this world okay there's some
kitchens that are the homeowners happy
homeowner type kitchen and then there
are kitchens that are certified to
prepare meals and yes it is true that
the legislature in its wisdom decide to
allow bed and breakfast is to use that
happy homeowner
kitchen but it limited it only to
breakfast and what you're coming back in
and says is no that's not good
enough it should be able to have the
full kitchen that we allow for
restaurants so it's not just the leech
field because uh yes it is true if
you're in a community that doesn't have
Town sewer you would have to have a
special leech field that's got a
trap and we've learned about that in
this committee okay about that trap and
then we've also learned okay is that it
needs to have more sinks than you would
think four because you not only have the
three sinks for doing the washing the
dishes you have to have a special
sink for whopping in the floors and and
that's where this particular constituent
because I did talk to her as you asked
me to and she what she was missing was a
the leech field with a trap and B she
didn't have the
extra
mop to clean sink well it's a followup
that I'm looking or we're looking uh the
sponsors this bill so someone could
actually get a cookie or a snack this
hasn't a full prepared meal that um you
know would require three sinks but if
someone she went out and bought the
cookies for instance I just presented to
you she can't legally under her permit
even give out a cookie so I think that's
a real
stretch okay all right thank you sir
much for your testimony any other
questions to the committee seeing none
chair will call up Colleen Smith who
you'll notice her name is down here on
this piece of paper
here and Colleen will tell you where
we're at with this issue have you seen
this
Colleen she wrote it I know but yes she
know she's absolutely familiar with
familiar with what it
is this is I have written my testimony
y and welcome back to the Commerce
Committee good morning thank you
chairman hunt and members of the
committee for allowing me to speak on
House Bill 30 1346 relative to food
service at a bed and breakfast I am the
administrator for the food protection
section within the department of the
Health and Human Services the department
is not taking a position on this bill
but I would like to provide some
information about the bed and breakfast
license so we do H license bed and
breakfast they are allowed to have it is
intended that it's the inkeeper home so
it's a residential kitchen with a
Residential Refrigerator a typical
residential kitchen sink um it's allowed
to have access to family members pets
are supposed to be removed um from food
preparation areas when someone's making
food but it is there's no septic
requirements we don't do a floor plan um
review as we would a a regular
commercial kitchen for a restaurant so
they do have limited requirements um we
were contacted by chairman hunt several
months ago about making some allow
allowance for a snack to be served under
consideration that some areas where bed
and breakfast is are located are en
rural communities which might not have
restaurants open at 9:00 p.m. for a late
night guest and so we did um propose a
change in our administrative rules to
allow for the service of a snack five
times a month for late arriving guests
um
so those administrative rules are due to
go before doar on the middle of February
with that change in mind Our concern
about the the bill as written is that it
it calls for meals and there's no
limitation if we put meals in statute
there would be no limitations so a bed
and breakfast could do um C they could
have a wedding on site where there would
we would be subject to a lot larger
quantities that maybe this residential
kitchen wouldn't be suited to handle
safely so our concern about that term
meals is there's no um boundaries on
that or limits as to what someone could
do um the concern that was brought up
about cookies so we do allow Homestead
food operations and they can do baked
goods in their home um so that would be
something that this it this facility
would be allowed to do is offer uh it
it's something that's allowed not only
for bed and breakfast but anyone that
has a home Kitchen in our jurisdiction
is allowed to do direct a consumer sales
without a food license so that and
that's limited to things like cookies
brownies things that don't require
refrigeration for
safety uh if I if there are any
questions for the committee from the
committee I'd be happy to take
those yes
sorry thank you with take my question so
you just said um cookies five five times
five times a month or five times a no
she's saying cookies anytime no but
cookies in any time no before before
that statement you made a statement
about F five days um so so the snack we
didn't put any um limit we didn't put
any context around what a snack could be
so it could be something like a s
sandwich that c that currently isn't
allowed is other meals besides breakfast
aren't currently allowed under the
current Rule and
statute so uh just a follow for the
question follow the homestead um act I
mean they they can bake cookies there do
they need a homestead
a licensed to do Homestead cooking so
there are so most homesteads are exempt
from a license that do um direct a
consumer sales and they also are allowed
to even sell at retail stores without a
license the only time they need a
license for us and again they they're
allowed to have a residential home
kitchen is if they want to sell via the
Internet or to restaurants where there's
not necessarily that direct to Consumer
interface so so just yeah just another
followup so it doesn't seem like there's
a problem if they yeah would you believe
I I if there was unclarity around this
particular licy you know we'd happy be
happy to reach back out till say that
they currently even before our rule
changed which would allow them to make
something like a sandwich they they're
not they're not restricted to offering
baked goods that's something that's
allowed in other instances so we
wouldn't so there there's no dollar am
amount limit on this on the bigs some
reason I remember there was some Bill
that had a $10,000 Li last session the
dollar amount was was um taken away soed
yeah so there there's no longer a dollar
limit on what a homestead can make right
well that's kind of weird because you
know a Double Tree they give me a cookie
and I just want to make sure that a bed
and breakfast can give
cookies okay any other questions yes
represent pelli thank you clarification
so are you saying that um if we
eliminated the word meal from this bill
would we still need it or snacks are
already covered under a different
statute so we we have a proposing rule
to frame up a limit on the the snacks so
I I would say if you are going to put it
in statute maybe we would may need to
have and there's no limit on it maybe
some clarity around what a snack is is
so I'm trying to you know play ahead and
figure out what the disposition of this
next step would be so there seems to be
a question about meal yeah the next step
is that is the rule now because you sent
me that your letter on did you send that
to all the members or did I I'm the only
one who got that I I just passed out
copies of the written testimony that
includes our language that will be in
the so includes what's the language of
the of the rule right so this is this is
when I called her earlier and I I've
been some of you might know about we're
supposed to keep eye on Ru making and I
watch it every month to see when this
rule hearing was coming up and and and
finally saw that it did hit that uh this
Ru making will be U entered um to and
that and this R new rule will then
supersede this statement here where it
says no sax uh so what you will see is
this piece of paper will change the the
annual license will change and will
state this new rule change that you can
have SN up to six snacks per month now
obviously nobody's keeping track of that
it's not a it's not it's just a you know
um the point being is don't make a habit
of doing it every night don't don't say
to your all your guests that we're going
to make you sandwiches every night okay
that it's it's a it's a oneoff on
occasion that you check in and at Peter
bro all the restaurants are closed at
9:00 so that you can at least get a
sandwich from the bed and breakfast
facility
okay I thought we had this problem
solved but evidently represent leash
didn't think
so okay and represent
grassie yes uh thank you um this thing
about limiting the snacks to five times
a month or six times a month whatever it
is I I really have a problem that maybe
we have to provide a definition for
snacks
and if you could come up with with some
sort of definition for that because I
think that you know I don't see a
problem with them providing snacks
anytime uh throughout the month and you
know you could have a a bed and
breakfast that you know or it could be a
a house with the Brady Bunch living in
it you're probably going to have as many
meals and being quite familiar with
restaurant Services as well most of what
I think they're looking to propose I
mean there may be some stuff here that
weddings and and other events that may
be a problem but you know you don't
really need a grease trap from making a
BLT or uh making you know there's a lot
of bacon greas very well it all depends
on how you do it maybe I pick the wrong
one but making a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich you don't need a grease strap
for um you know and I don't see them
making Ian as I said they could be the
Brady Bunch you make grease trap you you
make BLTs for all the kids in that
family it's it's going to be fine in the
septic system um you know as long as
they not looking at a professional
kitchen here I don't see a problem with
this and I think that you know we should
I would support having no restriction on
snacks um assuming that a snack was only
a cold cut sandwich that could be
something that it could be something
that is not a cooked meal or maybe
that's what we have to look at have some
sort of definition for or a pre
pre-prepare prepared thing that they
could bring in from offsite where all
they're doing is disposing of the waste
preprepared would be is not an issue
here right pre prepare would be is
absolutely you can go get that the issue
with that case is whether they're
charging for it
so but that if that obviously a any
hotel guest uh or bed breakfast guest if
they brought food in from somewhere else
then you know that's that's not what's
in question here the question was they
show up at at
9:30 and said you know we missed dinner
can is there anything you could do to
help us yeah if they had like a a sub
sandwich or something that so what
you're looking for is a definition of
that snack of a snack so that we can
make it unlimited because I think if you
you put five in or you put a number in
it's unenforceable well the five and six
is really that the intent on that is not
so much to what about the snack itself
that was intent is not the person not
the bed and breakfast to do it
routinely but I don't see a problem with
that I understand you don't but the
problem was that the legislature in its
wisdom so if you want to put this to
study we can talk about but in its
wisdom it decided that to H be a
restaurant MH okay not you know and
because remember this was a the the
breakfast wasn't was an exception to the
rule that the legislature passed and its
wisdom to be nice to bed and breakfast
is but that the rule always been and and
we would have Hospitality to come in
Restaurant Association to say to them
don't start saying oh bed and breakfast
is are now even exempt from the
restaurant requirements
oh yeah right then they're going to be
very upset they're going to come and
argue with wait a second now you make us
put these traps in you make us have
these extra sinks and you make us do
these things and you're going to let the
the bed breakfast to get away with it
and have catering events with 200 people
right I understand that okay I
understand that and I and I will and I
will see this at jel car next month as
well because
iard so what you're asking for is to
have a definition of snacks yeah okay is
that possible sure you know we we were
just trying to fra frame it so that it
was limited so that it wouldn't go to
the extent of you know they have a a
late night menu now and that it becomes
it it starts to grow or or again it can
be a wedding event that that now it it
things seem to morph on their own so we
were just trying to have some language
that would frame it up and limit it so
that it was just to accommodate a late
arriving guest to without um you know
being undue being reasonable that there
is no other solution for them to go out
and get a a meal in the
area any othere yes refes M um thank you
um I I could see somebody showing up at
uh on Friday afternoon and asking for
something to eat and and the proprietor
is saying well I already handed out five
Snickers bars I can't give you anything
uh as per per event as opposed to
numbering it uh how about the term
occasional snack that seems to me to to
fit the the bill and people can figure
out what occasional means but I don't
think any the devil's in the details
isn't it now it is always but thank
you uh okay any other
questions thank you very much uh I had
one one more card left Dan Maguire who I
assume is a
co-sponsor
yep he
is not thank you very much Mr chairman
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Dan Maguire I
represent the town of Epsom and yes I'm
a co-sponsor of this bill um and it's
it's very simple I I'm someone who uh
patronizes bed and breakfast I don't
know once a year once every other year
something like that and I would think it
super strange whether they're in New
Hampshire or elsewhere if they did not
have snacks right I mean it's very very
common that a bed and breakfast will
have uh a cuing coffee maker a um plate
of cookies uh a cheese and crackers
maybe at 4:00 you know maybe even wine
at 4:00 you know stuff like that no all
right well it's very common whether it's
allowed are not allowed because they
probably are a restaurant license they
probably have the restaurant
license some of them do I doubt it but
anyways um some of them are very small
right some of them are ordinary homes
they don't have weird kitchens and all
this sort of stuff so so personally now
at at the previous public hearing I was
in this morning representative Smith
cautioned me on the benefits of uh
compromise and so I would be happy if on
line four you removed and
meals and just put snacks right and and
because it's very common to have like I
said simple snacks
crackers chips whatever um and and and
if I went to a bed and breakfast that
didn't have that I would somehow think
it's not not as good right I mean it's
just it's just that that's how common it
is now um this question about late meals
I don't personally think that makes any
sense because um when I travel I think
about what meals am I having right I
mean I I I keep in mind well I'm going
to be here at such and such a time I'm
going to be there at such and such a
time I don't expect if I arrived at a at
a hotel or a bed and breakfast at 9:00
all of a sudden there's going to make
meals for me I mean that that doesn't
make any sense to me so
I don't think you need to go that that
far I think the simple bill without the
an
meals uh let the let the department put
the definition of snacks into
rules that's the end of the story right
I mean very
simple fair enough thank
you okay with that anybody else wants to
testify uh represent grass you want to
grab the blue sheet for me on
for
1346 do you
SE no great great thing about the
vacation model we
had I think that's for the next
one okay6 13466 she signed signed in
yeah okay all right with that I will
close the public
hearing
and the next one is in three
minutes you Ed that one perfect huh good
go downstairs
co-sponsor
11:00
Colleen
you got
do
okay okay we'll open up the public
hearing on
1702 and hear from the prime sponsor
representative
Lehman thank you Mr chairman uh
representative Maguire is handing out
some supportive
documentation my letter that I'm going
to read is still hung up upstairs in the
computer and I'm going to bring it down
as shortly as the system unfreezes
so anyway thank you Mr chairman uh for
the record my name is Peter leean I
represent Peter Brown Sharon I'm a
member of the finance committee and
Joint legislative fiscal
committee I have been a member of the
finance committee division one for eight
terms during my time on the finance
committee I have become increasingly
concerned over the operation of the
Liquor
Commission it was anticipated in
2009 when the Liquor Commission became
an Enterprise agency or
fund that Revenue would see a noteworthy
increase and the commission would run
more like a business than an
overregulation government
agency since
2009 total revenue growth to the general
fund has been relatively
flat in
2023 net profits before transfers
decreased by
6.4% or
11.6
million and Debt Service has been
increasing
too this year alone the commission shows
a
15.4% increase in Debt
Service as a member of the fiscal
committee I have the respons possibility
to review financial and performance
audits not only of the Liquor Commission
but every department and state
government The Liquor Commission audits
are always an interesting read and that
they differ dramatically from those of
other agencies in which they choose to
report The Liquor Commission with its
employees is a
$775 million a year business business
with 68 outlets and upwards of $77
million in product
inventory despite new and renovated
stores revenues are declining over the
last few
years in 2021 to
2022 sorry decline in revenues of $31
million in FY 2022 and
23 another decline of revenues of about
$16 million
a decline in Revenue impacts the funds
return to the general fund and the
alcohol Abuse Prevention and treatment
fund
aapf RSA 176 colon 16 Roman numeral 3 by
reducing funds available to this
important
program of some concern the legislative
budget assistant LBA on December 22nd
and the review of the commission's
financials see observation 4 attached
the LBA noted
quote the commission did not compute its
Financial year 2022 transfers to the
alcohol Abuse Prevention and treatment
fund again
aapf in accordance with the statute as
of today and according to the attached
liquor transfer statement from the state
treasurer the commission has yet to
address this payment to the aapf and
you'll see that supportive document in
the information that Mr Maguire
representative McGuire handed
out
additionally RSA 17 I'm sorry
776 col and 16 Roman num one requires
the Liquor Commission to transfer any
excessive funds to the general fund
daily however the commission has elected
to make the those deposits on a monthly
basis despite of what RSA
176 colon 6 Roman numer 1 specifically
States the LBA management letter of
December 18th 2020 expressed concerns
over the lack of a formal risk
assessment process end of
quote the commission responded that
quote the commission is actively in the
process of creating a for formal
internal audit in Compliance Unit to
provide independent and objective
evaluation of internal controls and
compliance related
matters two years
later in an LBA management letter dated
December 20th
2022 noted the commission quote has not
fully developed and implemented or
implementated an internal audit function
appropriate for the size and compl
lexity of its
operation back on August 26
2016 in a division one work session on
House Bill 406 FN
representative Danielson offered an
amendment to repeal the liquor
fund representative Smith said it best
and I quote the Enterprise fund was to
improve Revenue but those goals have not
been achieved at the same work session
Senator Chuck Moore said the Liquor
Commission needs more time due to
competition I am not sure the long-term
Sol what the long-term solution is
Perhaps it is time to privatize liquor
sales in New Hampshire as so many other
states have
done one could argue that revenues are
off due to competition Co or a number of
other factors
however if you look at the recent New
Hampshire Lottery Commission as an
example I'll see attached their revenues
in f23 are up 12.4% or $66
million with an increased transfer of
29% or 43 million to the education trust
fund one more troubling aspect
concerning Liquor Commission is it is
not uncommon to receive a letter or a
phone call call from someone claiming to
be an employee of the Liquor Commission
with a serious
complaint the last letter I received is
attached and was forwarded to the
justice department for review finally Mr
chairman I know that you are the goto
guy see attached when it comes to liquor
and I'm looking forward to a healthy
debate regarding the Liquor Commission
going
forward now I would like to add there's
been a lot of uh emails and phone calls
back and forth that I've received over
the last couple of days where people
thought the bill called for the removal
of the governor's Commission on alcohol
abuse that is not true
um uh is somebody also as far as Granite
State Advantage there was some current
uh concern expressed that this was also
going to be eliminated but as one of the
Prime sponsors of both bills that
brought us the New Hampshire Health
protection plan initially and the
granite state advantage that couldn't be
further from the truth I do have an
amendment Mr chairman um based on my
conversations with Kate fry several
weeks back at new Futures uh concerning
Medicaid expansion and as you know the
um money to take care of the state
portion comes out of the net proceeds or
the profits um from The Liquor
Commission and what the amendments
specifically does is move that to the
liquor
commissions um gross revenues versus net
profits as U Miss fry pointed out
there's is a feeling in the legislature
that this money should not come from
General funds and something like the
Liquor Commission but those of us very
familiar with the funding aspect of this
know that any money that doesn't go to
the uh net profits of the Liquor
Commission does doesn't go to the
general fund so the grab is done before
it goes to the general fund so it's
still State money but it would be coming
out of the liquor fund versus the
general
fund so I think that's all I have to
testify and certainly would welcome any
questions Mr
chairman
okay representative Barz thanks for
taking my question are you familiar with
the uh drinking Trends in the United
States and what direction those are
going in they are going going down can I
follow up further question main question
would you believe that part of that
decrease is due to the drinking cits of
Millennials are going way down and
they're going from an average of four to
three drinks um a year and so liquor
sales are off across the country I do
know that is correct and uh marijuana
sales are up I was just going to say and
and uh I was going to say there's people
going across the border now to get the
Cannabis so they're not drinking as
much of course it is maybe they're
buying their booze in Massachusetts
because they were already heading down
there to buy their
marijuana okay represent
spirit thank you so I went I went online
and I looked at what the liquor fund
does and one of the things it does is it
it looks for Grants from the federal
government to help with uh counteracting
alcohol abuse and that sort of thing so
my question is if we we don't are you
intending to just get rid of the fund or
are you intending to move it seems like
being able to get federal grants to
support this kind of activity is very
useful we're not suggesting it just goes
away are we oh absolutely not prior to
2009 and uh thank you for your question
um The Liquor Commission basically had
to get permission from the state
treasurer for spending now they have
that authority to do that without great
oversight as you know um the problem is
that with sales going down liquor sales
Nationwide as representative Burl stated
um the liquor fund for supporting uh
Granite advantage and the alcohol fund
the funds available may be reduced or
have been reduced you'll see one of the
attachments it shows the amount of money
has been reduced to the um New Hampshire
not New Hampshire Advantage but the um
Medicare Advanced funds that are
required and the alcohol funds
especially at the alcohol funds have
been reduced excuse
me but there would be no impact on any
fun federal funds received by this
bill okay so not withstanding I've got a
pile of cards here if everybody's all
freaked out that you're the pitchforks I
was told were out today so assuming that
we make it clear to everybody that that
was not your intent with this bill it's
clearly not in the bill and the bill
doesn't take effect several people
called me and said this is going to
happen this year and I said if you look
at the Bill's effective date is July of
25 the next bium budget so it's possible
that whether the governor or the finance
committee could say that um the alcohol
fund should be funded with General funds
and I would specifically support that
because looking at 5% you don't know
what that could be it's been it's going
to decline because of decreasing
revenues and perhaps um it should be 6%
or of set number in the budget so that
would be funded with General funds so
you're saying that theoretically um
passing this bill might mean that the
the uh they will get more money I would
hope so okay is it
so their concern should not not be about
what the less money I would it let's sck
to what the purpose of this bill is okay
the purpose of this bill is that when
the legislature made the decision to
change the nature of the Liquor
Commission so that it wasn't uh let's
put it for better or worse micromanaged
by legislators through the budgetary
process that as a member of the finance
committee you guys certainly feel that
it was a failed experiment to do this
and that the commission is not running
efficiently and that you think that you
the finance committee can be more e you
can ensure that it is a more efficient
operation if you took over and
micromanaged its budget I don't think
knowing my colleagues would micromanage
but let me respond to what happened in
2009 I was on the committee of
conference when this came up it came up
in the middle of the night it was
offered by then state senator Hassen to
make the liquor fund into an Enterprise
fund there was no public hearing there
was no public hearing Mr
chairman and I regret what was done
because it was late often things get
introduced late you've been on hundreds
of Committees of conference not
everything is done out in the open if
you will and uh we passed on July 17th
on that Amendment um to make the Liquor
Commission a special fund and there was
no public hearing before your committee
or anybody else it was offered by the
Senate during the committee of
conference
negotiations um obviously I uh my memory
is uh uh in terms of whether the
committee actually had had a hearing I
do not remember that so but I do
remember the conversation about why we
were doing it and the thrust of doing it
was that it made more sense that we
treat The Liquor Commission as a profit
Center as a business and so therefore uh
the example I remember U and I'm trying
to remember who was who said it but it
was um someone from uh the department
was talking about how um if if a car
crashed through the window of a liquor
store you remember that story that's the
example in the Liquor Commission at the
time said they would probably have to
wait a week before they got
authorization replace Council had to
approve the uh replacement of the window
so if you remember me that there was
some kind of discussion about why we
were doing this that that certainly
sounds like there was a some kind of
public hearing we did know what we were
doing were wide open at that point in my
recollection there was no public hearing
there was discussion among people about
they couldn't get a window fixed and
perhaps that was done in the hall but
there was no public hearing this was
introduced at a committee of conference
okay best of my knowledge best and it
probably was house build too it was okay
which we all know is is a place where
non gerain he bills can get stuck in
willy-nilly
so I guess I wanted do here's my point
to you okay not withstanding that I know
I'm holding all these people back who
are just ready to stick their pitchforks
in you and which you have tried your
best to assure them that that was not
your intent I'm just trying to get at
your real intent is that you want to
bring the Liquor Commission back in to
the general fund and have the finance
committee I assume you're going to need
a new division for it because it must be
rather busy to look at through all the
stuff that that department does that you
think you can better manage it that the
state would be better managed if we
didn't have as an independent fund that
we had it in the general fund just like
other departments like Health and Human
Services I don't know if I can say it
would be better
managed uh as you know the finance
committee my division that I chair uh
meets for six weeks to review many
dozens of budgets and branches of
government billions of dollars is in six
weeks all I've asked for and the chair
knows it's not the first time I've been
before this committee with concerns with
the Liquor Commission is that they
follow the
law you know the deposits are made
monthly versus daily the treasur office
has been trying to negotiate to get the
money they owe the drug agency over a
million dollars to get that settled you
know if those issues were settled Mr
chairman I probably wouldn't be here but
I've been on the fiscal committee long
time and if I look at their audits and I
compare them with the Department of
Transportation I don't want to say
anymore but I'm not I'm not very
disappointed I'm I'm not alone I've got
a number of sponsors on this bill that
serve on the finance committee uh we
just like them to follow the rules just
like everybody else fair
enough thank you very much for your
testimony thanks for your time Mr
chairman
oh I'm sorry we do have a question sure
yes uh thank you for uh coming before us
uh I have a
question is this your handout that is
mine yeah I'm still waiting for my
written testimony that they said it's
frozen in the computer upstairs perhaps
the chair had something to do with that
but oh followup why do people put these
pow follow up further question main
question uh the last three pages of this
handout
uh what's the
relevance well that was a complaints um
members that are sitting behind me have
gotten phone calls complaints when I get
a complaint unfortunately the complaints
that whether I've got them or other
members uh people are afraid to put
their names to them I there's a miles
that I deal with at the Attorney
General's office and he said until the
complaints people put their names on
there's not much we can do but we don't
get complaints from anybody else and I
know that probably doesn't act say as a
it's a good example but that's why that
is just just an example of one of the
written complaints that someone went to
the trouble of to send to my home in
Peter I don't the last page is a letter
with no author that's how I said people
are afraid to put their names on them
that so it's hard to act but we do get
those complaints sir and final you
already had a
final over over the last week we've
gotten I know all of us gotten a hundred
uh emails on
1702 nobody failed to put their name on
it thank you would you believe I believe
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman for your courtesy always a
pleasure seeing you
chair we call in Dan
Maguire who is a co-sponsor of the bill
and a member of the finance
committee thank you very much Mr
chairman once again Dan Maguire from
Epsom yes I am the vice chair of
division one of finance and another
member of our uh division is
representative Grassley grassy who's
also part of your committee um so I'm in
favor of this bill for the purpose Pur
for the reason that I'm against
automatic
spending right the the um the this um
treatment fund gets this automatic 5%
from the liquor fund it goes up and down
um based on whatever the liquor fund
happens to do and it and there's no
thought behind is that the right amount
to spend is that the wrong amount to
spend should we spending more should we
spending less what we do on the finance
committee is we have we sift through
request for funds from from thousands
and thousands of different angles and we
prioritize and we figure out should
should we spend on this how much how
does it compare to that and so on that's
our job and so when there's automatic
spending like this it h it makes things
more diff difficult for us because if we
wanted first of all there's a little bit
of an out of sight out of mind kind of
aspect that's why this is done because
people who want this don't want close
scrutiny on on what they're doing
generally speaking and um so so things
that don't directly affect the general
fund get less scrutiny from us than
others right and so
what the What that particular fund
should do is it should be part of the
normal division three process where they
decide how much funds go to Medicaid how
much funds go to recovery how much funds
go to this that and the other thing
right and and it should be balanced
against all the other requests that we
get now it could be when maybe the the
consumption of liquor is going down but
the problems with drugs are going up
and this fund needs extra money right I
mean um it's just I'm I'm against this
kind of automatic spending and it's it's
riddled throughout the budget quite
frankly I mean this is one little piece
I mean this doesn't solve the whole
problem it's one little thing but why
not fix this now while it's in front of
us an example I had in the budget just
recently was the affordable housing fund
right we when there are three different
affordable housing funds and when that
came to our committee we have to decide
are we putting 10 million here and 15
million there and 20 million there what
are we doing with this well it turns out
one of these particular affordable
housing funds gets an automatic 5
million from um uh I think it's the real
estate transfer tax right off the top
and we don't see that right it's it's
it's we see okay how much General funds
am I using for this that and the other
thing and so we don't that's not part of
our thinking when it's automatic like
that so it's it's and I only discovered
that just recently because the Senate
has a bill to it tank the five million
and make it 10 million so you know um so
anyways the point of that
is let's have normal
oversight over these kind of funds
including The Liquor Commission and one
more thing I'll say this your example
about the broken window Etc I don't I
don't think that's realistic right we
had a case this this last time with the
um Department of Corrections and the
commissioner of the Department of
Corrections wanted um a small uh amount
of of spending Authority so that she
could reward guards who performed above
and beyond the the Call of Duty right
that that um give them a present give
them a little party give them a
something when they do something good
and so we did that right we're not we're
open to when when Commissioners come
before us and they say I need a little
spending Authority for such and such a
purpose right like the broken window or
whatever we give we give that right I
mean it's
it's it's not something where we we have
to you know I don't get a list of well I
bought a I I bought a typewriter
ribbon if such a thing still exists
right and we approve it I mean we don't
do that sort of stuff we budget right
and this will give this much oversight
over an area that has been problematic
and gets very little oversight at this
time okay uh representative Gibbs has a
question
thank you uh and thank you for
testifying this morning um isn't it
possible that what you've described uh
as automatic funding uh isn't it
possible that there are some programs uh
perhaps important programs that need
consistency of funding uh in order to be
able to plan and operate in a consistent
Manner and that that is the reason why
there are specific allocations of
percentages or dollar amounts so that
the those programs are not subject to
bial
uncertainty yeah I I guess I don't agree
I mean I
think
there's having they get certainty every
two
years in general we don't eliminate
anything but we adjust right we we push
a little this way or that way
um now there are certain funds there are
certain dedicated funds that are there
for constitutional reasons like the
highway fund for example right so the
Constitution says Highway funds can't be
intermingled with General funds right so
we that we do that right there there's
other similar things but in this case
this isn't a
consideration represent ma later uh
thank you chairman um as as a previous
uh was previously said by another
representative is that there seems to be
a misconception as to what this bill
does and I've got a lot of emails as
everybody else do had saying let's itl
this because they're going to totally
discontinue the alcohol fund what went
wrong there and how can you correct that
perception yeah I think it's as
representative Lehman said the effective
date of this bill is the same date as
the new budget starts
s right so um the new budget will start
on July 1st
2025 right a a year and a half from now
so that's when the next budget will will
take place so knowing that that alcohol
and and Drug fund will not be
automatically um funded this way the
department that runs it will come to
finance and put it in their budget
they'll put it in their budget it'll be
a line I'm in in the budget it'll be a 5
minute or 10 however long discussion
when when division three looks at that
budget right so it's not going to be dis
it's not disappearing it's just the
automatic nature of it is is what's
disappearing you
see okay thank you very much thank um is
representative Smith I don't see her
yeah I I think she had to leave for her
own committing okay and then normally we
next person up would be former
representative Ned G and I see he's no
longer in the room uh he is opposed to
the bill as proposed so I assume he
would be uh focusing on the same issue
that everybody else is focusing on so
now we'll get into all the opposition to
this bill and so all I can ask is uh
please when you your testimony of here
that that the sponsor did not mean that
to discontinue These funds but I can see
that the argument of the guaranteeing
dollar amounts versus the flexibility
that the finance committee might change
those things and every banum is a POS is
a possibility so uh Rob Barry and
David
Ernie uh d David had to step out but I
do have Daniel Higgins with me and
Jennifer Higgins great um so we did Mark
oh for the record Rob Barry general
counsel Division of Medicaid for New
Hampshire
DHHS I'm Jenny O Higgins legislatively
aison for Behavioral Health with DHHS uh
so to respect uh the committee and and
your point Mr chairman we're not going
to belabor anything that U our testimony
was primarily centered on the bill is
introduced uh I did understand from
representative Lehman that our concerns
at least as far as the granted Advantage
piece uh may be addressed an amendment I
look forward to reviewing that language
and uh and working with the sponsor on
that but our our biggest concern was how
uh the conversion of the liquor fund to
General funds May upend the grant
Advantage Program which is statutorily
prohibited from utilizing General funds
and that's all I'll have to say about
that so additionally from the behavioral
health perspective the the portion of
the revenue that funds the governor's
commission um does allow for flexibility
where we have many Grant restrictions
and so in New Hampshire where our
funding sources for the substance use
Continuum of Care often rely on federal
grants with two-year Cycles the
stability and predictability of this
Revenue uh allows for us to do more
long-term planning and consistency in
that Service delivery and also there is
a specific and really valuable tie to
being the sole owner and operator of all
liquor stores and then coupled with our
responsibility of running the substance
use disorder Continuum of Care that we
really bear an obligation to reinvest
that Revenue into prevention treatment
and Recovery to mitigate harm to our
communities so the you know data linking
alcohol to societal costs and harm is
overwhelming and alcohol continues to be
one of the most commonly misused
substances so that is a very specific
linkage to those revenues coming back
into the community to mitigate that
harm okay so the rationale of having
connected to this liquor fund rather
than the general funds is is important
in terms of why we have this both to
mitigate harm as well as the flexibility
that it allows for how the funds are
used and are directed by the governor's
commission which has a strategic plan
forward and obligates these These funds
on based on very specific need in New
Hampshire and how they invest great
thanks oh we do r b thank you for taking
my question uh the federal funds that
you're talking about um did do they need
a match from no so just the federal
funds often have restrictions including
sometimes they're very substance
specific like our opioid Grant dollars
need to be used only for opioid and
stimulant use disorders so this funding
source allows for some flexibility to
really look at how do we invest in New
Hampshire across our Continuum of Care
and for people who may have poly
substance use
right thank you very much thank you okay
um before I go on i' just been a text
that evidently the governor has signed
the blue sheet uh in opposition to this
bill and then I will have Patrick tus
from the governor's
commission we'll beat this one to
death do I look like a
villager I'll be great
yeah hit the microphone hit the hit the
button there you go perfect thank you Mr
chairman committee members I'll be brief
um I just want to say that I did have a
conversation with representative
leechman and I really respect the intent
of what he's trying to do which is to um
guarantee more funds to help people
dealing with substance use disorder in
the state of New Hampshire we share that
concern um I am opposed and the
governor's commission is opposed to the
bill as written because the lack of
guarantees as to how we would fund the
tremendous work that the governor's
commission is doing um I've heard uh
automated uh brought up um we need
predictability in order to do the work
that we're doing um I really
congratulate the legislators here in New
Hampshire for fully funding the
governor's Commission in this bium it is
the first time we have been fully funded
and the transparency and the outcomes of
the work that we're able to do is
included in this report and plan uh the
state of New Hampshire benefits greatly
from the New Hampshire Governor's
Commission on Alcohol and Other Drugs
you have assembled a tremendous amount
of content experts who are able to make
decisions and support the Department of
Health and Human Services to do
tremendous work that is flexible and
extremely relevant and also very local
here in New Hampshire um we are a able
to invest in and determine local
strategies that are in real time to what
we're facing here in our state that
aren't tied to Federal Regulations so I
won't belabor the point um I respect the
intent I am concerned about what this
would mean for the predictability of the
very important work that we do in the
state of New Hampshire because I would
replace the word automated with
predictability and in order to do good
measurable work over time which is what
we're trying to do you have to have
predictability so Mr chairman committee
members thank you very much for your
time I do have a letter in opposition to
the bill as well as the current
Governor's Commission on Alcohol and
Other Drugs strategic plan that I'll
make available to the committee thank
you thank you uh chair Colin Dr Larry
Kane s NH
HS not sure what that means
yeah hit the bread
button yes yeah this happens all the
time at home listen uh what is s nent
Southeastern New Hampshire Services I'm
on the board of that
organization that provides drug and
alcohol treatment it's a rehab in
Dover um you would like me to be short I
intend to be so short as to defer my
remarks to the executive director of
this organization who sits behind me um
but I definitely am opposed to this bill
um and I'm very much in favor of what
the legislature did to in the year 2000
to establish an alcohol fund for the
treatment and prevention of this Scourge
so um with that I'm going to uh step
aside but I hope that you will consider
a letter I've written and my comments
that this is an important uh piece of
New Hampshire now the alcohol fund and
it should be continued
um and it hasn't been funded properly in
my opinion until recently thank you for
that and thank you for your time thank
you
Jonathan jany is that who you
want I
see did I get it right yeah did Larry
leave the button pressed yeah he did
good okay hi I'm John Chaine I'm the
executive director of South Eastern New
Hampshire alcohol and drug abuse
services and I'm speaking in opposition
to the uh bill as written um thank you
for your time and thank you for
listening to me um yes I am the
executive director of a uh Treatment
Facility in DOA New Hampshire and uh the
points that have already been raised
very well this morning uh are absolutely
true we are at times hamstrung by
restrictions on federal funding and we
are reliant on consistent funding levels
to continue off operating the services
that we provide um alcohol use disorder
is a huge problem it remains a huge
problem we still will see a significant
number of people for whom alcohol is
their primary or sole drug of choice and
in order to treat those individuals we
require funds that are generally
applicable so my concern with the bill
as written is in paragraph 3 where it
specifies a portion of the gross profits
that establishes no flaw for this
funding level and that is my concern
there a portion is far too
ambiguous thank you okay any questions
the the Committee Member seeing none
thank you very much thank you uh chair
calling Kate
fry there she
is
good or good morning still right good
morning it's been a long morning um
members of the committee my name is Kate
fry I'm the vice president of advocacy
at new Futures I will be very brief I
have testimony in front of you we are
opposed to House Bill 1702 while I
respect where representative lman is
coming from as well we did want to um
point out the unintended consequences um
as you know we are a nonprofit
nonpartisan organization that work
um on policy change with policy maker
stakeholders and others to reduce
Alcohol and Other Drug problems in the
state so just to clarify as uh you've
probably heard while it repeals the
Liquor Commission fund and makes the
oversight of Liquor Commission funding
the bill also REM removes the
requirement for the state treasur to
credit all gross revenue from the sale
of alcohol to The Liquor Commission fund
and directs it to De be deposit in the
Jenner fund just to clear new Futures
does not have a position on the
oversight of the funding struction for
the Liquor Commission um or uh
um exactly sorry however new future
strongly opposes the portion of the bill
which removes the 5% requirement of
gross profits from alcohol sales to be
deposited into the alcohol abuse uh
prevention and treatment fund otherwise
known as the alcohol fund and instead
directs the legislature to set an amount
based on appropriation included in the
state operating budget using general
funds so while it doesn't repeal the
alcohol fund it does get rid of the 5%
and that's very important to us for
background purposes Finance through the
revenues generated from the liquor sales
in New Hampshire the alcohol abuse and
treatment fund was established in 2000
the intent behind the creation of the
fund was that a small very small portion
of gross profits 5% of substantial
revenues generated by the sale of
alcohol would be used for prevention
treatment and recovery and administrated
through the governor's Commission on
Alcohol and Other Drug as you heard from
Patrick tus so for context 5% of gross
Prof uh profits it's a drop in the
bucket compared to what um the revenue
is so in 2021 10.3 million was 5%
compared to the 81 million for revenues
although the alcohol fund is an innov
ative fiscally responsible Common Sense
approach to a very real need in New
Hampshire since its exception the fund
has been historically underfunded and
diverted elsewhere it was not until last
year 20 years later that the fund was
actually fully funded at the amount of
5% in the state's operating budget for
24 and
25 so this bill reverses that historical
by removing that requirement of 5% of
gross profits and just leaves up to the
legislature and amount based on the
appropriation included in the state
operating budget so we all know from 20
years of history and you have a chart in
your um pocket uh this appropriation
will likely be far below the
5% um so as said earlier it would also
just Dr up the funding structure for
Medicaid expansion there is a
Prohibition in the granite Health
Advantage law of the use of General
funds so now if a portion that used to
come out of the Liquor Commission fund
comes from General funds that's likely
to impact uh the entire Medicaid
expansion program which provides Health
Care coverage to more than 50,000
Granite Staters um so for these reasons
we ask you to vote an expedient to
legislate again I brought an alcohol
fund chart that shows you fully funded
versus what was actually appropriated
and just to clarify by the funding
actually increased uh in the past I
think you heard earlier that it's
decreased over there we finally got
fully funded uh this year so um we would
ask you to vote in expedient to
legislate I also have a one-pager on um
the abuse fund and the governor's
commission and some of the agencies that
re uh receive funding and I do want to
underscore the importance of even though
it said this would happen in two years
we have to remember the fragility of
many of these agencies uh Who deliver
this funding so the long-term planning
would really be impacted no matter what
even if it's in two years we have to be
able to look at the long-term
picture Okay um representative Gibbs has
a
question thank you um the question I'm
going to ask is based on my own
experience as an agency head dealing
with Federal funding and the agreements
on which that Federal fund in is often
based do you know if any of the federal
funds for alcohol abuse programs in New
Hampshire uh come via agreements that
include a provision stating that if the
expected consistent funding were to be
reduced that would violate the agreement
for the federal funding and imperil the
federal funding itself um thank you for
the question I believe that is that
could happen um I'm not an expert at
don't work at the department I do
believe that there could be language in
there but I do also want to underscore
what Miss oh higin said that the alcohol
fund because it's not General funds
provides tremendous around amount of
flexibility that can't be used um where
federal funds has more restrictions so
it really is an Innovative fund where
you can use um uh where there may be uh
restrictions where other with other
funding thank you very much thank you I
see the Gordon has
arrived good morning good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is n Gordon I live in the town of
Bristol and I'm not here as a judge
today
so I uh I'm here just uh as I read the
the Senate bill I was concerned because
it appeared to me that uh it was a
repeal of the uh alcohol fund uh that
was put in place a long time ago and and
I certainly would be opposed to doing
that and opposed to changing the funding
mechanism through the general fund I
think that there there should be a tie
between the alcohol commission and
funding and I think it says a lot about
the state in terms of um who we are and
what we
value alcohol you know alcohol the
initial fund was created because uh it
was well recognized that alcohol has a
has an effect that our our agency our
alcohol Commission in the state was
established to be a control agency
and has evolved over time into a
marketing
agency and because it is there are
consequences for marketing alcohol and
AR alcohol is recognized although we
have the opioid crisis and we have
people dying in this state and it
becomes uh you know pretty shocking when
you have sudden deaths like that but the
fact is that alcohol kills any a huge
amount a great a greater number over
time than drugs do other types of drugs
do it's it's a potent killer and that
doesn't mean that we should ban it but I
think what we should do our very best
job is to control it and uh the one
thing about the alcohol fund the alcohol
fund was intended to address issues with
regard to prevention and education
because you can't with regard to Alcohol
and Other Drugs you just can't treat
your way out of that problem treatment
isn't the answer prevention and
education is the most beneficial way of
approaching it so the reason I'm here
today is just to say that I would be
opposed to certainly doing away with the
alcohol fund all together but I would
also be opposed to doing the funding
mechanism through the general court and
uh through the general fund I think it
should stay linked to the alcohol Comm
commission that's the only lier
commission that's my only testimony
today perfect thank you very much thank
you very much members of the committee
Holly
Stevens representing
Nami
chairman hunt members of the committee
it's been a while since I've been here
uh my name is Holly Stevens and I am the
director of public policy at Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness Nami New Hampshire is a
nonprofit Grassroots organization whose
mission is to improve the lives of all
people impacted by mental illness and
suicide through support education and
advocacy and on behalf of Nami New
Hampshire I'm here today to speak in
opposition to House Bill
1702 have you as you have um heard um
this uh bill would put um the Medicaid
expansion program in Jeopardy currently
under New Hampshire law um the program
um allows for the use of Liquor
Commission funds in the event that under
other funding sources are insufficient
to fund the program and I have included
the uh the RSA for your reference and I
can um go through that if you would like
to show you where it says that um and
additionally as you've heard um the
granted Advantage um program is
prohibited from using any general funds
and I have not seen in this bill where
uh it would allow that program to use
General funds in the event that other
funding sources are insufficient to fund
the
program of of all the challenges facing
Granite Staters our Mental Health crisis
is
Paramount in New Hampshire
221,000 adults have a mental health
condition and 15,000 minors ages 12 to
17 have depression and yes a lot of
those folks right now are covered by
Commercial Insurance um however at any
point in time um somebody can lose their
job and if that happens um and granted
Advantage wasn't there as a safety net
they would be unable to continue their
Ser the services that they have in place
um like other medical illnesses delays
in treatment mean progression of serious
of the seriousness of the illness and
more difficulty and cost when the person
eventually does receive treatment so if
there was a gap in their treatment um it
would be more severe and more costly in
the end um for those living with mental
illness these delays can result in
outstanding personal and productive
losses that harm the livelihoods and
could be
life-threatening in 2021 of the adults
in New Hampshire who did not receive
Mental Health Care nearly 42% didn't
receive it because they couldn't afford
it and this bill as it's written um if
they lost their insurance that's more
folks that would not be able to afford
their care we also know that in our in
states that have expanded um Medicaid
more children are end up being covered
by Insurance just by happen stance the
research bears that out so um it also
would affect the kiddos um in the state
that are covered by Insurance the
positive impact of grite granite
Advantage um
has an improving access to care is
obvious in
2021 through the Medicaid expansion
program over 11,000 Unique Individuals
received mental health outpatient
services nearly 830 accessed in patient
psychiatric hospitalization and over
26,500 obtained mental health
medication um so you know Nami New
Hampshire applauds the current success
of the granted Advantage program and the
legislators who have supported that
program
um however House Bill 1702 could put all
that work in Jeopardy and therefore we
do oppose this bill and I'll take any
questions that anybody
has I think we're questioned out thank
you very much thank you
uh chair Callin John
baren from SOS recovery Community
organization you gota push the
button my name is John Burns I'm the
executive director for SOS recovery
Community
organization and we have peer-based
recovery centers in do Rochester and
Hampton New
Hampshire um as well as a social
Enterprise Workforce development project
as a restaurant in summersworth New
Hampshire um
and I I want to speak in opposition to
this bill um I appreciate the intent and
but I do think that there will be some
unintended consequences to it and
especially as has been said the
flexibility so to give a couple examples
we have two contracts that come to mind
that come through the governor's
commission um one is through as a
subcontract of What's called the
facility ating organization which which
funds all of the recovery Community
organizations across the state in that
funding it's a braided mix of SSA block
grant funding State opioid response
money that comes from the federal
government as well as Governor's
commission alcohol
funds and that braiding is really
important because because there's a lot
of activities that we engage in in our
recovery centers and a lot of programs
that we do that would have restrictions
from that SSA money whether it be State
opioid response or the SSA block grant
that some of those things we just
wouldn't be able to do if we didn't have
that alcohol fund and we didn't have
that money coming from the governor's
commission so it's essential for us to
do the things we do and we're serving in
the in our three centers we have over
11,000 visits a a year coming into our
centers so it's a substantial
population um with not a lot of money
and then we also run a family support
contract across the state which which
helps prop up and expand family um
support groups which are mutual Aid
groups mostly run by volunteers and to
build the capacity around that across
the state that again is also funded
through the governor's commission from
the alcohol fund and again if we didn't
have that money the flexibility that we
have to work with those volunteers and
some of the programs and some of the
trainings we do we train them on
facilitating we train them on suicide
prevention we work with them to build
capacity and we just wouldn't have that
flexibility based on some of the you
know quite frankly ridiculous
restrictions that often come with
Federal funding that that tie our hands
on a lot of things we do so I just want
to stress that flexibility as an
organization um and I also want to say
you know to the to the point that Kate
fry made from new futures um the alcohol
fund's been a long around a long time
I've been in this work since
2013 I can't think of a bium that I
didn't have to come in front of the
finance committee and beg them not to
pull money and divert money out of the
alcohol fund as it is so when I hear
that the intent is to provide more
funding and put it on a general ledger
line item I have concerns about that
because we've only been fully funded
last year and you know the one year it
gets fully funded we're now facing
somebody uh legislation to to repeal the
entire alcohol fund um so I have a lot
of concerns about that but I would
welcome the primary sponsor and any
co-sponsors that do want to see
additional funding to put another
additional funding General line item in
that General budget in the finance
committee we would certainly welcome
that and I think most of the agencies
that are impacted by the alcohol fund
would accept additional funding we
certainly could use it so I thank you
all for your time and appreciate the
opportunity to speak to
this thank
you uh Jim
manahan oh
good so Jim represents uh by state new
Futures ACS Solutions cbhl I but he is
in opposition to the bill I would have
to say that Jim is the first person who
told me about this crisis this bill was
going to
create so uh Kim
Bach post to the
bill
good morning and thank you for your time
my name is Kim Bach I'm the executive
director with the New Hampshire
Coalition of recovery residences and we
receive our support and and our ability
to operate from the governor's
commission um what we do is for the most
part we certify voluntarily certify that
recovery h Homes across New Hampshire
use best practices and are safe ethical
places for people in recovery to get
their lives back on track
there's no licensing requirement for
those homes in New Hampshire and that's
typical across the United
States I think it's really important
that there's money guaranteed to go
towards this purpose to go towards
everything that the Govern Governor's
commission supports from from prevention
through treatment through recovery
Support Services we have National Data
that tells us
that 12% of Americans suffer from
addiction 70% of that is
alcohol most of the funds as as Jenny
suggested most of the funds if we've had
mixed funds we have to be really careful
about is it just alcohol this person is
addicted to or is there other substances
because the federal funding is often
limited to other substances that's what
sells the news that's what is popular
right now so alcohol funding is very
very very limited but that's still 70%
of the problem the great news is that
recovery from
addiction it's 80% by recovery that's
long-term remission meaning that with
all these support services that are
offered to people in New Hampshire we
can reduce the time to get to sustain
recovery from an average of 15 years to
an average of five years and their their
risk of overdose or
of death from their addiction comes back
to the same risk as the general
population the alcohol fund does really
great
work all of us working together provide
those services that are very important I
understand the bill isn't intended to
take away all the funding that there
would still be funding there but we also
deal with nimbyism and nimbyism is not
in my back my backyard and as the
legislature changes in population ideas
change and there's no guarantee that
they would have the same
priorities to work with people with
addiction that that are guaranteed if a
certain percentage of the funds are put
in that direction so I oppose the Bill
thank you okay thank
you uh did I just see Jim walk in or did
he walk back out SE in and out okay
Kimberly
Haley
hi good morning um so I've been a
prevention councelor in the state of New
Hampshire since
1988 so I was here when the alcohol fund
um came into
existence
and I've also seen the fund not fully
funded year after year after year after
year um with lots of
frustration
um with all due respect to the uh
Representatives who put 1702 together
which I oppose um it's it feels more and
more the more people up here talking to
me it feels more like a little bait and
switch um you know the the governor's
commission um has a bunch of
representatives from the prevention
treatment and Recovery Community who
advised the commission on how money
should be
spent now these Representatives say no
problem okay the alcohol fund's not
going away we're just going to let the
general fund fiscal people you know
handle it you just you just give us your
budget and we'll take care of you you
know that that's what they're making it
sound like that's not the way it's going
to go okay because
they've barely ever funded the alcohol
Fund in full who's to say they put a
diamme in for prevention treatment and
Recovery you know oh sorry we have these
other expenditures you know we we can't
help you you know and one of the reasons
why it's important that it goes
automatically into the fund because it
guarantees just something something to
work with
and um when you're sitting there with
with budgets away from the commission
these people don't have in their mind
who these Cuts you know or lack of
funding are going to impact you know you
got to ask the people that work in the
trenches okay with with the
Fallout from um people consuming alcohol
and Other Drugs okay so the people
making these decisions I doubt you have
ever sat in the room with a 13-year-old
who lives with family substance use who
wants to die who's talking about dying
because they have no hope for their
future okay people working in the
trenches help that kid through Services
figure out why they do have help that
their life can be different than the one
that they were born into you know I'm
not sure these people have ever gone to
a prevention program in a school and
followed a prevention Council around to
see what they really do how do these
Services benefit anybody right have they
ever gone into a treatment center and
talked to some of the clients and what
they're getting out of these Services
have they ever gone to a Recovery Center
you know when they're providing some
activity on a Sunday afternoon that's
keeping people from using have you ever
experienced that so when you're sitting
in some room with a pile of money in a
general fund you're not going to be
thinking about these people unless you
make the effort to actually
go and visit some of these
programs
um it is incredibly unethical immoral to
me that a
state receives a pile of money from the
sale of a legal
drug but we have to
battle for people to take responsibility
to clean up the mess on Isle
five
okay in the form of
addiction okay one in four kids in the
state of New Hampshire lives with a
caretaker who has an alcohol
disorder one in 11 lives with a
caretaker who has another drug
disorder okay that's a lot of
kids I work as a consultant with
prevention counselors
Statewide and I can tell you these
prevention programs are now going down
into elementary
schools because we have fourth graders
bringing alcohol to
school and these people want you to
think that oh alcohol sales are going
down that's a good thing well they're
right that's a good thing ask yourself
why because people are in the
trenches helping
people so they either will grow up and
not drink until they're in their 20s and
avoid addiction or they're helping them
get treatment and they're supporting
them once they're
sober that's
why and the time is not now to like oh
we we don't have to worry so much okay
we've got to adolescent selling drugs on
Snapchat fake bills from China that have
fentol in them okay this is this is what
we're dealing with and we're talking
about oh don't worry your money will be
safe in the general fund no it won't
it's a bait and switch and it's a
lie and we'll be lucky to get
anything
and I urge you to oppose this
Bill thank you thank you for your
testimony got one
C two seconds you sorry I just I just
want to thank you for what you said
because I think it's it's a lesson for
people who are legislators to get out of
this building and go see what's
happening not just in terms of alcohol
addiction but drug addiction a lot of
other issues so I just want to thank you
for that thank you very
much okay I got one card left Ava
Hawks and since you wear an orange bat
I'm going to hold you to one minute
perfect thank you Mr chair members of
the committee I will be very brief um I
am here for the record my name is Ava
Hawks and I'm the director of advocacy
for the New Hampshire Medical Society we
are here opposed to House Bill 1702 for
reasons that have been expressed at
length today uh we are just very
concerned with the unintended
consequences of this bill impacting the
funding structure for Medicaid and I
will leave it at that and I'm happy to
take any
questions perfect thank you very much
thank
you so represent LE I'm not sure how why
my uh letter to the editor made it in
here but I want to assure you I've never
had a phone call or an email where
someone says they want to get rid of the
the liquor fund well I would like to
respond not to the last speaker but the
previous speaker before her and the
allegation that we as legislators don't
know what's going on I lost my son to um
aent all overdose so that testimony in
attacking the sponsor than me personally
when I know what it's like that's wrong
and I know that the sponsors want to see
more funding and restricting it to 5%
it's not appropriate but to make an
allegation that those people whether
your people sitting around the table or
the sponsors don't know what's going on
is wrong I hear you you're right thank
you okay I will close the public
hearing
yeah it's it's a public
policy be taking a
position when he
are you
back Co see you
then no I'm g go back to the office yeah
I'll let you know I'll probably leave
around um I ask everybody to who's not
interested in this next be to please
clear out as quickly as possible because
we're hopelessly
behind Okay represent
s
okay so hey Keith did you fill out a
card
or
okay all right let's
go
all right Keith you're
on all right good afternoon or good
morning still good morning good morning
Commerce Committee I'm introducing uh
House Bill 1540 for the record my name
is Representative Keith Amon from
Hillsboro District
42 I'm a co-sponsor on the
bill and I'll just describe briefly what
the bill
does um it's it changes what restaurants
um have to uh
provide
um and uh adds a new
definition there's a list of different
types of meals that can be
provided um and it changes some of the
the guest uh
numbers and um adds one or more tables
so it reduces the numbers of of tables
that can that are
required uh and
uh the meals should be readily available
and served to the table the menu shall
contain multiple options of full course
meals from at least two different meal
categories that are listed and you can
see that they start on line
six and uh with that um I don't know if
I'm qualified to take a whole lot of
questions on this and I know there's
probably people behind me that uh that
will have more detailed answers so but
I'd open up for questions if there are
any so what is the intent of the bill uh
it's to um allow for Less uh
requirements for um I think basically
service alcohol right isn't that the
idea so um that you had to have
um a meal that required table wear that
you couldn't eat it standing up like so
we're we're reducing that and adding
different types of meals to it so you
could have a salad or a wrap or because
I think what I've heard on this
committee for the last three plus years
is we don't want people drinking alcohol
without anything in their
stomach and that's really the issue is
that it slows the absor absorption rate
of alcohol if you have food readily
available so I think this new
definition um still allows for that you
can eat a sandwich you can eat a wrap
you can eat a salad um and that meets
the requirements so that that's my
understanding good any questions from
the committee members of represent
W thank you thank you for taking my
question can you just tell me what a
national super stew
is a national super stew right on line
17 line 17 I'm just curious I've never
heard of that is that Campbell I can
answer that if you'd like it it's a it
may be a a regional term that we may not
use around here oh like a CH it is from
uh yeah campo's website it is whole
bunch of definitions for different types
of St stews and soups and I just
included all of them in when I was
writing the Bill thank you maybe it's a
Italian Italian wedding soup or
something right not not homemade let's
put it that
way okay but you know I was really
disappointed when Campbell pulled the
pea soup off the market for a while but
it's it's back now so it's back in and
and that might be a stew because it's
got ham and peas thank you very much for
your testimony thank you do you have a
question oh sorry you do realize he said
he might not know the answer what what
about
Chows Chows um I guess that could be
considered a stew or soup are I'm is
cereal a soup it's got reps of am I'm
sorry I couldn't resist I'm just kidding
okay than you this is this is all within
family here so we can be a little bit
lighter about this
okay all right Mike tell us
why
you you uh took no position on this bill
uh I did not um so good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record Mike Summers president CEO
the New Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association um we actually uh appreciate
the effort to try to Define food this
has been somewhat of a struggle over the
years um so we're actually okay with
that and look forward to working with
the subcommittee assuming there going to
be a subcommittee of course um where we
have a little bit of concern with the
bill is the reduction down to 10 guests
at one time uh you know 10 guess is
basically a takeout counter frankly so I
don't know that we necessarily want to
have a full service restaurant distilled
Spirits Etc at a takeout restaurant so
again look forward to working with the
subcommittee on that and working through
those uh and certainly happy to hear
where the commission is on all of this
so uh that's
it
oh I guess you're allowed to ask a
question because you
didn't testify um now I get it why that
Happ would you would you believe
would you believe that I actually just
spoke with the commission and so I think
in working committee we're going to
actually change that part that you're
raising in concern with to the language
will read something to the effect of
we'll leave the 20 as is unless under
discretion by The Liquor Commission and
that'll give them freedom to look at it
the motivation behind that specific part
is there is a restaurant I learned about
in the North Conway area that my my
brother's a plumber and he was doing
Plumbing for them and they didn't even
know that his brother was a c rat but
they were just venting about how they
can't get a full liquor license because
they can only put 14 seats in there and
he wants to be able to serve like
martinis and stuff it's just a cafe
higher end I guess so um it just seemed
kind of ridiculous to me which is why I
put it in there but then the Liquor
Commission has a pretty good suggestion
for the language so I imagine we'll
we'll adjust it in the working s session
look forward to seeing the language
obviously um but again I I will also say
having worked in the restaurant industry
it's awful hard to make it make it in
this industry with 15 seats so just for
what it's worth but if you have Al yeah
but even then I mean 5050 can't have to
your alcohol can only be 50% of the
revenue just real quick I'm just curious
which restaurant it is because it'll
give me a visual because I'm from that
area no I me understand it better he'll
tell you
later all right thank you thank you uh
enforcement you going to come in and
tell
us speak to us anyone which way about
this one or you going to leave it all up
to the
subcommittee thank you Mr chairman uh
for the record uh Mark armaganian chief
of enforcement and Licensing for the
Liquor Commission with me here today uh
is Danielle Elston deputy director and
and deputy chief um there have been a
lot of discussions on this this and we
appreciate representative Sullivan and
and uh this whole committee on being uh
receptive to open conversations on this
like we always are um uh the deputy
chief who can speak more about this has
uh been very active with conversations
with uh representative suvin on this
issue um I think we can get
someplace um there are there's some
things we have to work out and there's
some uh there's some verbage that needs
to definitely be defined but I think at
some point in subcommittee we can get to
that point so not to Echo the words of
Mike but uh uh I I do Echo uh exactly
what he said that I think that there's
some good stuff that was brought up and
there are some other things that other
problems that we have dealt with in this
category that we don't want to see arise
as an unintended consequence fair enough
Danielle you want to say
anything Sor okay we're all set then any
questions from the committee members
represent San you have any
questions okay thank you very much uh
represent grassy you want to see if
there's anybody signed in on that blue
sheet you didn't know that joining this
committee means you had to get up
and sit
down
okay representative Jonah wheeler sign
the failure his next one's his I don't
know if he wants me to do it we're we're
not there yet we got to gavel this first
one down I was
trying okay so who's going to
testify okay this one's yeah so you you
will fill out a pin card after
afterwards yeah thank you all right
we'll open up the public hearing to
House Bill 1374 and you got five minutes
no okay yeah so this is two very subtle
tweaks to the existing law um one of
them is to change and I'm sure I'm going
to get Flack for it but anyways we're
changing the so the current law for
those of you who don't know on this on
this committee I'm sure many of you do
the current law says that if you don't
sell $775,000 worth of food in a year
then you need to sell 50% of your
revenue from food and so I think for
those smaller restaurants that don't
have the ability to sell maybe 75,000 a
year that's that's a big burden and so I
just reduce it down to 15% it doesn't
mean that they get rid of their kitchen
doesn't mean they get rid of serving
food of course you still have to get 15%
of it it seemed like less of a burden
for these smaller cafes particularly
when they're in their early startup
phases um then the other one which sort
of came as more an observation is the
idea that that they have to be open 5
days a week in order to have be able to
sell alcohol I thought that was a bit of
a burden and I adjusted it particularly
up where I live where a lot of our
business is tourism and you start to get
to the slower you know the shoulder
Seasons we're talking April May and
November a lot of places are really slow
and they want to be able to open only 3
or 4 days a week not 5 days a week
because they just literally can't make
money doing it and so we're forcing them
to be open when it's not profitable
during those slower times of the year um
so yes that was the motivation of
changing that down to three days a week
and yeah those those are the basic uh
the basic ideas here any
questions representative
burrow this thanks this is a uh would
you believe in high tourist areas like
like the where we are in the North
Country um even some of the big
restaurants can't stay open 5 days a
week because they can't get help and
because there's no he housing for
workers so I mean I think that's a
problem not just for small so I I think
I think that's a good point in the bill
yeah
thanks would you believe yes okay I know
represent M
you thanks representative San for
bringing this up um on line 14 should it
be limited to the evening meal or should
just be any
meal
um
so that is existing law so I just
changed the five to a three so we could
change that that's something people are
concerned about but um that's just I
just was trying to minimize the amount
of changes to make it a little bit
easier to follow do you think it might
make it even more flexible if they could
you know not not necessarily an evening
meal like maybe a Sunday brunch or I
mean I love the idea making things more
flexible so I'm totally open to
that okay so um yes I've been around too
long so that 75 was actually reduced at
one point in time was all the way up to
150 then was 100 and then
75 and the idea is that
um when it comes to the 50/50 was really
the the most important
number because that when you get down to
that Dom Minimus number if you're just
15% and and three days a week that you
know this boy that sure of looks like
just a bar that's not a
restaurant when you're doing that low
and I think that that's a reason why the
legislature has never gone
there yeah I I understand the motivation
behind that
um I don't know if that's entirely an
accurate way to think about it and we
certainly can have this discussion in in
the subcommittee but the way I look at
it is there are places that are
primarily bars for good chunks of the
day already in some places even in the
state with that you know you go to
Manchester downtown places they're
they're open I know there's different
licenses I'm not trying to go into that
but what I'm saying
is we're still allowing people to open
up establishments that sell w liquor H
sorry that can't sell liquor but can
sell beer and wine and have not this
requirement and so the only what makes
that not a bar I know places that are
set up this way that feel like a bar
but they're just selling beer and wine
and mixed cocktails that are you know
premixed so the all intents of purposes
it's essentially the same people still
are capable of getting drunk by drinking
beer or wine or seltzers or canned
margaritas and so I think that that is
if if we're truly terrified of bars as
we seem to be in this state I feel like
we need to acknowledge that there's an
inconsistency in it right now and I I'm
trying to address that with this well
it's similar to the fact that um that
same category you talking about the beer
and wine and the in the pre-made
cocktails which are lower alcohol than
if you were to actually make a drink is
the same thing when it comes to their
beverage distributors versus the State
Liquor Commission that the tent to the
legislature all the way back to 1834 was
that yes that the distilled is a
different category and that the only
people who should be in the distilling
business are the people who have sered
meals dinner you know full full-fledged
meals yeah I mean somebody thought that
at some point I don't know that the
majority of people share that view and I
also think this back in 1834 in 1934
yeah right coming straight out of
prohibition I'm sure they had real
cleare eyed Vision on on what alcohol La
what they were they afraid of um they
just got rid of the prohibition they we
just got rid of prohibition I'm sure
they were super open-minded about
opening up the doors but no I mean I
think at the end of the day if I drink
10 beers and drive home from a
restaurant that's a concern if I
drink there no bar no facility would
ever give you 10 beers okay but what
whatever you get my my point you know
don't get hung up on the numbers try to
understand my intent of what I'm saying
which is if I over consume beer or wine
and drive home that's a problem or act
like a jerk outside that's a problem
those things that happen whether we're
selling beer and wine or whether we're
selling liquor and I struggle to
understand what the fundamental
difference is between somebody drinking
a couple margaritas or Gonic or drinking
several beers and being
inebriated the outcome is the same
you've consumed some level of alcohol
that imp impairs you and so the idea
that we have this special regulation and
we still will have a special regulation
because there is no requirement on food
SA sales as a percentage of total
revenue if you just have a beer or wine
license what it does do is it makes
people who maybe don't enjoy beer or
wine from being able to go to these
places um I I think it's I I think it's
inconsistent and I'm trying to like work
on that a little bit right and and I
know you realize it but I just make sure
all the committee understands that it's
not just beer and wine it's up to 14% so
those pre-made margaritas pre-made
drinks um are are available as an option
right okay so we do have questions on
this side we'll start with
representative
taxton uh I guess this is a point of
inquiry or
clarification while I hardly support the
idea of reducing the requirement from
five days to three days for all the
reasons already stated I am not quite
clear
on the current law is if my food food
sales drop under
$75,000 a
year uh then I have to say my my my food
sales are $50,000 a year whatever that
is 25 only I have a limit of 25,000 in
uh alcohol sales and 2 I have to have
another offsetting 25,000 in food sales
is that correct essentially yeah so if
you don't sell $75,000 worth of food so
we're not talking total revenue we're
talking just food Revenue just food then
then 50% of your total revenue in that I
can't sell more than $25,000 worth of
alcohol if I sell in my example of 50
yeah so I sell
$25,000 worth of if you're total revenue
is 50 if your total revenue is 50 if
you're selling $50,000 worth of food you
can sell up to $50,000 worth of alcohol
got it all right so my total revenue is
50 I can do 25 and 25 if I sell 50,000
in food I can sell 50,000 in Boose right
got it I'm not sure 15% seems really low
to me I mean I agree with the chair
you're really running a bar at that
point so at so it's it's sort of the
inconsistency my argument is the
inconsistency with the current liquor
laws that we have so like I said you can
sell as much beer and wine as you want
and that does not matter it's only the
hard alcohol portion and I just think if
we're worried about overc consumption or
it's hard to know what the intent is
because like you know the chairman said
that this was written coming out of
prohibition and who knows what they were
thinking um but it it it to me it's just
a it's a blatant inconsistency it's
really glaring when you look at it and
it and it is preventing businesses from
operating the way they want and I think
that this is the Commerce Committee we
should try to be making it easier for
businesses to run and not have burdis
some regulations
that don't clearly serve a public
benefit and and I haven't heard somebody
make a strong case as to why this little
car out for just the hard alcohol
portion is is important but you did say
you understood that having food was a
good
thing I'm I'm fine with the food I mean
I think I think having food
is most likely what's going to happen no
matter what because there even in places
where other states where there are no
food requirements most places that sell
alcohol have food so I think I mean what
I believe is we all know what I believe
I believe in the free market let them do
what they want but I think that having
I'm not trying to get rid of food I'm
just trying to make it easier for people
to create establishments that are
potentially productive but are
prohibited by our ownis regul there
could be the unattended consequence that
they might sell very little food at all
that but at least they have food as an
option like I think that's that is is
what I would think the intent is like
are we trying to force food on people or
we okay well I don't I don't think we
should force food on force people to eat
food yes so I I have a problem with that
but then why aren't we doing that for
beer and wine that's that's where I
think we beer and wine used to be there
and that was that was look so we are
capable of changing we are like I said
we started the food requirement started
I think when I first got here it was 150
right so you know so we've chipped away
at it over time make it a little bit
better okay representative Gibbs
uh thank you uh just to throw out as a
possibility uh representative Sullivan
um in terms of percent required
percentage for food sales would you be
open to something between 15% and 50%
yeah I'm open to
negotiation thank you let's make a deal
okay
here have you heard anything from anyone
that's specifically a business owner or
somebody trying to start a business that
say that that is indicating that this is
what's stopping them from opening their
business yes that's that's the
motivation behind this
bill can you tell me what the context of
that yes they have a I so there's two
cases and one of them that I'm more
familiar with uh they have a business
going and they can only sell beer and
wine and they are not capable of
building out a full kitchen to meet this
requirement it's also a small space
they make the 20 seat requirements so
that doesn't impact them um but they
they don't really if they were to build
out enough to to do a full restaurant
they do sell food as is because that's
is a requirement and they they it's
pretty good food but they cook it off
site and bring it in
and so they they just aren't able to
really I don't know if they are I don't
know if they would even hit the 15% to
be honest but um I I'm not part of the
business but I do know that right now
that they are not eligible to be able to
and that's the primary motivation behind
this is like I just saw it firsthand
that this is a pretty honorous
regulation that is preventing this
establishment from fully
running represent
bull um just a clarification are they a
restaurant do they have a restaurant
license if yeah I mean there there's no
bars in New Hampshire so of course they
have a restaurant license right do they
have but do you just you just said that
they bring the food in they prepare it
offsite and then they cook they like
heat it up and cook it there yeah
so is it LIC is it licensed with the
DHHS the kitchen is the kitchen licensed
with no it wouldn't be A's yeah would it
would be It's usually the town's uh code
Code
Enforcer it's licensed it's open it's
I'll take you there if you want
make great
tacos okay you're you're do they have do
they have a full kitchen no they don't
have a full kitchen okay they have a
preparing they have a space where they
do they do prepare food they don't they
don't have the three sinks or the or the
no they have the three sinks they have
the three sinks no no you got to have
the three sinks for cleaning but then
you got to have another two sinks for
washing the floor so I bet you they
don't have no they do they have they
have that they had all the sinks they
have the sinks yeah they just don't have
the septic system no they have Town SE
and water they don't have they don't
have they don't have stoves they don't
have you know whatever yeah deep fryers
that sort of stuff okay represent grassy
yeah uh would you believe that I'm
familiar with with a restaurant similar
to that or a place it's basically a brew
pub but they serve food that they get
from another restaurant that prepares it
for them and they just resell it at
their place they cannot sell alcoholic
beverages as well and and other than
beer and wine and I think that's what
your bill is is attempting to address
you know they they they they sell
appetizers basically as pretzels yes so
under the beer and wine license you have
to have some food available we didn't
get into the big deal about it and that
was and that that yes I was in the room
when we passed that but they wouldn't be
able to sell mixed drinks right and I
would the distilled ones that are o that
are not premixed that was the that was
the distinction I was trying to get
across I would believe and I would
believe that's now three that I've heard
of so I'm sure there's more I'm sure
there are plenty of other businesses
that would be made that would benefit
from this regulation and this isn't
quite softening in the way that the beer
and Line license apparently was Sofer at
some point so thank you very much all
right all right
Mike
good uh morning afternoon Mr chairman uh
members of the committee Mike Summers
with the logic and Restaurant
Association uh we are actually opposed
to this bill we have concerns um
interesting discussions you're having um
I think the example over here to my
right I believe that's a nano brewery
license if I'm not mistaken not a brew
pub a brew pub has the ability to sell
uh mixed drinks Etc BR pu definitely has
distill but they have the full food
requirement they do full-blown kitchen
correct
um so going back to the uh testimony of
the sponsor of the bill and certainly
appreciate the bringing this bill
forward um you know if you're not
producing the food on the site I I don't
know that you need to have a full-blown
liquor license and and I'd also just
take a step back you know the comment
about you know can can somebody do
enough sales to meet the 50% or
$75,000 you're gross sales would have
only have to be $150,000 and you already
meet the 50% requirement or the 7
$75,000 $150,000 in this industry is
nothing most McDonald's are over a
million dollar in sales in any given
year so that is a very low threshold and
in fact uh in talking to a lot of our
members a number of them actually
suggest we should maintain the 50% and
potentially take the $75,000 up to what
chairman hun mentioned a minute ago
somewhere in the neighborhood of
$150,000 and to just give some
perspective here because sometimes it's
easy to talk about a big number and get
lost but at the $75,000 threshold that's
only
$1,443 a week in food
sales it's about $289 a day if you're
open five days a week that's nothing
that's you know five six eight guests at
you know cheeseburger and a drink um and
at 150,000 it's it's less than $3,000 a
week and it's about $577 a day if you're
open five days a week um the other
concern we have obviously is moving the
threshold from 5 days to 3 days and I
would also say and I believe if
Department's going to testify but right
now there is a mechanism in the statute
that allows for if you uh get a full
service liquid license you can apply to
the liquid commission to get that
reduced to two two days three days
whatever so there is already a mechanism
in place for the commission to add its
discretion to allow business to to Cy
come down to a lower number of days and
again I go back to the Staffing comment
earlier we've certainly seen that we've
experienced that we've shared an update
with our members to make sure that if
you go less than five days make sure you
talk to the liquor enforcement
investigators make sure that they're uh
they're aware of what you're doing so um
those are our concerns and obviously
look forward to a subcommittee work
session so with that I'd be happy to
answer any questions okay representative
taon so you represent the restaurant
owners is that correct a lot of them yes
about about a third of the industry we
represent and so I I think I probably
basically agree with you on the the the
numbers but I also believe people have
the right to
fail uh and I recognized I did the same
Matthew did and came up with $1,400 in
change a week and said well that's
almost not worth showing up for if
that's your gross receipts you're not
going to make it as a you're not going
to make it but maybe as you said a food
cart or something which then that's a
different argument so I I agree with you
wholeheartedly on leaving it at 50% but
I do have a concern over the
what over your opposition to the
reduction of the number of days from
five days to three days and what's
counted as a day because it's
apparently uh U Sunday brunches would
not be aren't counted I'm not that
familiar with it but as uh God knows the
worst thing you could want as a real
estate agent to be involved in a a
running a restaurant that's a one of the
many keys to failure we're pretty good
agreed pretty good at using bars but um
the so my my question is if you could
develop your reasoning
behind not reducing it to five days
because I see people attempting to
operate restaurants and they're
profitable three days of the week and
they're basically paying to be open a
day or two a week and this has always
troubled me I as a business owner myself
I thought God if you guys just closed up
two days a week you'd be okay so if you
could explain to me why they have to be
there five days a week I'd really like
to know so the five days is just the
current standard and as I as I mentioned
there is a mechanism already built in
the statute that you can operate for
Less days it's just a process you go
through with uh The Liquor Commission
and and during the course of the
pandemic we had an awful lot of
businesses that applied for a less than
five days and were and received it
simply because they didn't have Staffing
right we went through a whole thing and
so our position is that the mechanism to
accomplish the three days is already in
the statute so we don't know that it
needs to be uh necessarily changed we
also think that there in order to
operate a full service restaurant which
is distilled Spirits you know full bar
the whole bit that there should be some
guard rails in place and I would just
like to mention I forgot to say it in my
testimony but this committee uh not two
weeks ago passed unanimously the
penalties for uh over service for um uh
serious injury and death resulting
increased it by 300% so it seems a
little bit counterintuitive that it
would not make a whole lot of sense to
start to ease those restrictions uh
where we I think would agree that having
food available and consumed whilst
consuming alcohol is probably part of a
mitigating factor in these particular
relationships but I'll get off the soap
box you'll never forgive us for that
will you representative ta all things
heal in time well so in the case of
further inqu
given that I agree with everything that
you just said except how are five days a
week a guard rep what he's saying is is
and I thought we had this legislation
years ago I think Jean Chandler put it
in for someone up in North Conway that
we that you could be less than five days
but you had to make a request to the
commission so maybe we just need to
write that into the statute I guess we
did that by It Isn't So it's just not
not in this it's not included in the
bill but there's another section correct
it's just
another I don't have my glasses on sorry
oh I don't so that's current law
then and exemption exemption right and
and the commission has usually been very
receptive to just tell us why you need
to do it and no problem and that was my
that was my memory so but unfortunately
I didn't have the bill in front of me so
I could have said I think I wrote that
Amendment okay okay represent gives
thank you um regardless of the specific
numbers and you probably heard me a few
minutes ago suggesting that there might
be a percentage number somewhere between
15% and 50% that would be appropriate
but regardless of the specific numbers
or calculating it out to the dollar
amounts and so forth um having heard
representative Sullivan tell us that
there is at least one and it wasn't
clear whether there might be three that
he knows of but at least one that one
business that he knows of um that has
told him that the current uh statutes um
prevent that business from operating in
the way that they believe would be most
beneficial uh presumably most profitable
and also provide the best service to
their customers it's not clear to me um
what the basis is for um opposing
greater
flexibility normally I would agree with
you but I think the issue you're going
to find and I'm actually going to defer
part of the qu your question to um
liquor enforcement because my
understanding is in order to have a full
service liquor license you are required
to have a fullservice commercial
kitchen I believe that's true and so if
this uh particular company cannot or is
already space restri red where they
cannot put in a full service kitchen
changing this is not going to help them
because ultimately they cannot bring
food from outside and serve it and then
say that they are meeting the food
requirement it was one of our
frustrations under the Nano
Brewery uh progression let's call it
progression where we we slowly whittel
away any food requirements whatsoever
and now they can actually have somebody
else bring it in from outside
so but I will defer to the commission on
that but I believe that that is the case
they need to have a full a full
commercial kitchen in order to meet the
food requirement regardless of whether
it's 15% or
50% correct that's what I thought right
and I would just say that when it came
to the Brew Pub legislation that that
they had to be they they they held them
to that it had to be a restaurant that's
right and and therefore they to get the
license they had to go for the full
liquor license the 1280 because but they
could sell the stilled but they had that
was the that was the deal that was
struck to create the The Brew pup
license which we'll learn more
about more to come more to come all
right
represent maybe this is a question for
the commission I I'm just curious does
the exemption is it indefinite or do you
have to reapply for the
exemption do you know
Daniel why don't you come on on up
everybody all done with Mr Summers okay
thank you
sir okay Danielle introduce yourself so
everybody knows who you are Danielle
Elon Deputy Chief of New Hampshire
Liquor enforcement um the exemption can
be um done at their license renewal if
they've already received it they can
request the exemption again at the time
that they renew and we can continue with
the exemption so it's not um the
renewals are approved so it can be a
continued
exemption okay any other questions to
the
Deputy
enforcer okay seeing none thank you uh
having Noone more to testify we will
close the public
hearing back and we' be back at
1:15
so for the record uh Kate fry who didn't
testify is in opposition to the
bill
for
let's do
it no this is not a
hearing so but the first thing you need
to do is that Sarah you need to turn
around and meet Sarah you must probably
know Sarah already I did meet Sarah and
she has an H in her name
okay was my mic on yes it was but I have
a Sarah without an H in my life so you
know the story right I do know the so
you got to make sure she has a copy she
has it okay and have you read it Sarah
do you like everything in
it uh not yet I just wanted I just
wanted a thumbs up or thumbs down how
about I thumb
sideways okay go
ahead um thank you very much Mr chair
and members of the subcommittee for the
record my name is Karen eel um um and I
represent marac district 7 and I'm here
to present to you um an amendment to hb1
1649 has this been passed out or what do
we have uh the clerk has it I made sure
to have it before we went to lunch you
had it I could have had
it but then again I might have spilled
my I I'll just my chili dog on it and
that wouldn't have been good I mean the
other thing that I gave the clerk which
I don't think had been distributed as a
Court lever letter from the professional
firefighters for the bill so you should
have two documents well I'm just hoping
if anybody has a problem with that
they're here in the room yes I tried to
make sure no one left had any problems
okay so tell me when you would like me
to start Mr chair and I'll walk through
the amendment okay this is a replace all
Amendment like that um and it's uh
toh so the first thing so Mr chair um
what I thought I would do is I'm just
going to walk through the bill um in
order of the pages and uh this will
reflect all the conversations that we
had last week at the work session so the
first thing I did was um we talked so if
you go down to page one um line between
line 28 and 29 there were three
definitions there one was for frat
fabric one was for fabric treatment and
one was fluorinated uh containers those
definitions have been
removed I mean I'll explain we'll just
go through and I'll explain everything
as we go okay so then on page two um
line
35 um I removed the reference to um and
methylene carbon atom
so that the remaining definition of
pasas uh conforms to the one most
uniformly used in the US but most
importantly conforms to the definition
that we have in our own statutes under
the firefighting foam
section um the next thing I did for
clarification um page
three whoops line 11 um I made sure uh
to note that uh P added product includes
a p added uh consumer product so it's an
all-encompassing
definition um on line 28 page line 25
page uh three does everybody have okay
um so you recall what I said earlier
that I removed the definition of fabric
um and I have replaced the definition of
fabric with the def it's identical but
it's textile um because there was all
there were words textile and fabric used
in here and I was trying to make things
more
uniform uh the next definition I added
was textile
Furnishings um because we're going to uh
discuss adding that to the product band
list it's what we talked about before
and then um line 30 one I have a
definition textile
treatment um that's basically that was
fabric treatment but I'm just trying
again to make the um make the
definitions more homogeneous still make
Scotch Guard I mean they make stuff yeah
and Scotchgard is still out there I mean
I can't they still make I mean you guys
talked about resolve with the fell from
Waste Management right carpet cleaner
and so I the but that's for resolves for
carpets that's clean well this is It's a
carpet cleaner right you're right okay
so um I believe yes they still make
these fabric treatments um and in fact I
think that some of that stuff is what's
even used by the carpet cleaning people
to treat the rugs so okay so that's that
um so the next section which is a very
important section and one that everyone
has been very interested in um it starts
on the top of page
four um this is the the so sections
three four and five are the new
exclusion sections the first one
excludes um from the coverage of this
law drugs and medical devices that are
um subject to regulation by the US Food
and Drug
Administration um so
basically dental floss and certain types
of PPE which are included in the product
band section are in fact medical devices
um approved by the FDA and I
communicated directly with the folks
that make these
things um and that's so I think it's
necessary to do this
exclusion um the next thing that I've
excluded is uh water
utilities and uh wastewater treatment
plants because they were concerned
because they handle things that have
pasas in them even though they're a
byproduct of their
processes uh that they not be considered
as subject to this bill at all which
they are not
um the next thing for the exclusion it's
actually something that the chair would
was very interested in so I'll have to
tell him about it when he comes back um
this is the exclusion for um hydr floral
olins which is uh hfos that's a
replacement refrigerant for a much more
hazardous refrigerant that has uh
deleterious effects on um on the climate
and ozone layers and everything so this
provision is basically uh it excludes
products that are approved under the
what they call the snap policy and also
under the American innovation and
Manufacturing act this has been
discussed with the lobbyists for
Honeywell and span um the sustainable P
Action Network they've approved the
language they've seen um the amended
language uh just clarifying that and
they've agreed to this the exemption
doesn't apply to products that are
banned by this act which for the most
part uh wouldn't have they don't have
refrigerants anyway but just in case
there was something in there um the next
thing page four uh line between line 15
and 16 this was where the notification
provision was and also the labeling
provision um I've removed each of those
sections as we discussed in their
entirety so they're totally
gone
um the next thing
uh is in the product ban section so if
we go to page five um number three had
been fabric treatments I renam that to
be textile treatments to do what I told
you I was doing um I've removed
fluorinated containers from this list
and I've also removed remove dental
floss and for those of you um when you
if you recall the last time there we did
talk about doing um an exclusion for um
products overseen by fifra which is the
the statute involved in
pesticides um I've gone back and forth
talking to the pesticide folks and I
decided at this point it was important
to keep our pesticides in their
containers and I have removed
fluorinated containers from this list
but um in lie of that I've added textile
uh Furnishings which is draperies and
things like that which we have inside
our house which are treated with p and
emit quite a bit of P um and textile
Furnishings I pointed out to you was
defined in the earlier part of the bill
um this is something that's also
supported by the waste industry um
because because textile Furnishings
carry an enormous
load so um now that the chairman is back
did you do you want to talk about the
exclusion language regarding the F hfos
okay um so um go back to page four
please um at the top uh these are the
three exclusions and I went went through
it already for the rest of the
subcommittee the first one is an
exclusion for drugs and medical devices
uh regulated by the FDA so that includes
certain types of PPE and um I've
communicated with the industry folks on
concerned about uh the PPE ban and I am
100% convinced that medical devices
approved by the FDA should not be
included in the coverage of the bill so
I've included an exclusion here um and
they're happy with that I've
communicated with them I do have drugs
as well even though drugs aren't really
covered by the bill it just all goes
together um number four is an exclusion
um to answer concerns of the Wastewater
and public water system utilities folks
they don't actually intentionally add
past to anything but they were really
concerned that the end product of uh
like sludge and things like that do have
P in them and they didn't want they were
really concerned that they might be
considered as somebody under this bill
and I'm excluding them entirely um I
worked with the New Hampshire uh
Municipal Association to nail down this
language accurately so the next um
exclusion is number five um I explained
it for the rest of the committee Mr
chair but this is the hfo exclusion um
and significant New Alternatives policy
program is snap that's the program that
um is uh sort of blesses alternatives to
much worse stuff like refrigerants hfc's
um and this is the language I work
closely with the lobbyists on they've
approved it they've seen this amendment
I I showed them the amendment the whole
thing before I shared it with you so um
and then there's an exemption for things
otherwise banned by the bill so that's
all right there they gave me the thumbs
up on all of
it um and then the only other thing uh
is on page six I have uh the language
requested by the chair which sunsets the
dees position 5 years after passage five
years after implementation of the
product
band
so um I actually went back and looked at
the YouTube I think I've got everything
here that we talked
about isn't that great that YouTube yes
it is you know it is you can relive
jokes and all kinds of right all that
stuff we missed all those years I've
been in the rep and we who knows now I
have people to rely on me telling the
story right so if you have any questions
okay any questions to committee
members I actually have a question thank
you if if somebody had a a product that
was highly concentrated in with past how
how do you dispose of
it um you know at the moment it's not
considered a hazardous material um so
but if it were me and I knew that it was
concentrated with pasas I would bring it
to the hazardous waste collection days
okay thank you oh yeah they would they
would take it um but if you look at the
statutes it hasn't yet been designated
as a hazardous
waste it's ski wax it's very
concentrated oh yeah evidently yeah yeah
it is I mean which we can add to our
product
van okay and everybody else said okay
okay thank you thank you okay
Sarah didn't you or me
it's I saw your
phone I'm
okay good afternoon I'm sorry that's
okay for the record my name is Sarah uas
Kern which is a mouthful so you can feel
free to call me Sarah Kar and I'm the
assistant director of the waste
management division at the Department of
Environmental
Services uh Dees has reviewed the
amendment that you were just
discussing and the amendment
significantly addresses a number of the
concerns that we expressed in our letter
of testimony from earlier this
month um that being said we remain
neutral on this bill however we look
forward to continuing to work with the
sponsor on it and we'll be following the
bill with great
interest okay now we I wasn't expecting
to S take a position but so we were more
worried about anything that was a fatal
flaw that we
we we believe we could implement it
based on the amendment okay so make sure
I understand now with these band set
these uh companies who produce anything
they're supposed to the clearing house
can you just review for everybody so we
all understand with the whole role of
the Clearing House and what what that's
all about sure and um with the
amendment we don't believe that it would
be 100% necessary for us to to implement
the Clearing House we wouldn't have to
implement it in the way the original
Bill fora we would recommend that uh the
state of New Hampshire get a membership
to the Clearing House which is much less
expensive than purchasing a module
having it designed for us so um in this
reduced role if we were to purchase a
membership that would cost about $7,000
a year for a membership and that would
help us to
learn about the Pas content of products
and help us to um coordinate with the
companies that are going to need to
submit their information to us I think
it would make it easier for the
manufacturers right because the the
overing problem is is every time I
say like food packaging so does there
any food packaging out there that have
past and I always get the same respones
nobody knows so what's always been the
most scariest part about this
legislation uh is that is I have no idea
what
I'm what we are regulating
here yes and there's information that
there's food packaging fast food
packaging that contains past things like
that uh in the first hearsay right
because we don't we can't actually
identify any packaging do we do we
actually know is there packaging I I
believe that we know that there's
packaging and number of other states
have banned food packaging with pasas
already um in the implementation period
if this bill was enacted uh the the
employee that the bill would put into
place would look into exactly this which
products have Pas uh there would be some
money for hiring a company to do some
testing uh so that we could get some
data yes and in that case at some point
um they could come running back to us
and look for that exemp in our exemption
section to be added to it if they can
make a case for why they deserve to be
Exempted
yes okay representative MCU thank you Mr
chairman thanks for coming to help us
with this today on the the nine things
that are mentioned as categories of
banned
items which of those produce
bioavailable or have bioavailable pasas
in them that are at the biggest biggest
risk for entering into the consumer's
body and can you give us an example of
you know XYZ product or
whatever
um I think it's perhaps a question more
for a toxicologist I'm a geologist but
it's possible that representative eel in
her research for this would be able to
um give you the answer for
that I can tell you um from where I sit
in the waste management division at Dees
that we hear from landfill operators
that one of their biggest concerns uh is
carpets added to landfills adding to the
Past content of the
Lei you know and clearly um anybody
who's in the waste management business
not just waste management but that they
all want us to pass this legislation
because they don't want to be on the
hook
for the water pollution
so what I'm asking is if you sit on your
Scotch Guard and couch or you're at a
higher risk of kidney cancer you set on
your SC couch who knows who knows we can
answer some of that you know for sure
I've read articles from the National
Institute of Health where they show that
they and and blood measurements where
they're showing how food packaging uh
can show that an article of food can be
in food packaging and show up in your
blood within minutes right uh articles
of uh what volatility from carpeting
showing it entering the bloodstreams of
children within minutes of crawling
around on a carpet this it is pretty
well known that it does we know that it
can happen but we don't know if it's
going to cause kidney cancer words they
put this way it would be a lot easier if
bunch of people were dying in a in a
certain neighborhood whatever because
they had that excuse me in some cases
they do if you want to read the right
literature you will find it if you
really want to dig for three hours like
I do okay they actually know what the
mechanism how the how the P molecules
are attaching themselves to the to the
uh fatty acids in the blood right which
clogs up the liver and clogs up the
kidneys they do autopsies and find
livers that are that are damaged Beyond
uh uh recuperation with cancer you're
johnas yeah but but that's what I'm
saying is but that we all have different
DNA that are susceptible and some are
not susceptible right and some of us are
ugly what does that
mean I'm not going to say pres company
included because we're all beautiful
people no the point being is is that we
know that it gets in BL we know all this
is true the problem we can't say is that
that
Pepsi is probably going to kill
me it's going to kill you we cannot say
Scotch
Guard you know that if you if you spray
Scotch card to tomorrow on your we
cannot say that you're G to I think
about was um Jordan's Furniture who you
always talk about how great their
Furniture was and and they're throwing
glasses of wine on the thing and saying
this is look what a Marvel this thing is
impenetrable this is a great service and
you all say what is on there and and if
we buy it am I going to die from it we
don't know don't know if if it looks
like a duck and it quacks like a duck
it's a duck yeah it's cumul cumulative
um impact right so if you're um using
Teflon is another one I don't know why
that's not in here but if you're using
you know nonstick
um pans every day I do and you're G okay
so that that myti life that that has te
in it that and aluminum so so and then
if you sit on your couch for three hours
so it's it's a combination of all that
plus if you have you know hereditary I
mean candles and then you have candles
you know in your bathroom and you're
burning that you know every day it's
just if we can eliminate some of these
toxins then that's what we need to do a
little bit I understand why we're doing
it okay I understand that chem we can
see that chem it's in our bodies it's
the problem is always been how do we
identify how do we know which one to
yank off the shelf and the reality of
this legislation is we don't we're just
taking the product
category and saying we don't want this
sold in our state anymore because we
don't know which carpet or which piece
of furniture or which carpet cleaner or
any of these we cannot say to any one
product this is easy to identify we want
to yank this from the Shelf
representative Gibbs is
next thank
you we don't know which carpet is going
to kill which person and we don't
know that any particular type of carpet
is going to kill everybody but from what
we've heard so far both this year and
last year is that we know that a certain
number of products in this category are
going to kill a number of people because
we've had people testify that they have
cancer that has been identified as being
caused by this category of product and
because of
that I would say that's a good enough
reason to not have those products sold
in the state of New Hampshire because
it's going to kill some people and I'd
rather not kill
them
representative I I would represent to
you that if we pass this bill you're
going to see products that are going to
come on the market that they're going to
be labeled that they don't have past
free right right so so that's no reason
not to go through with this because we
don't know which saying I am not arguing
about I'm just saying is my frustration
and obviously is not your frustration
because you guys all think we should
just pass this legislation because
somebody came in and said I got cancer
oh come on okay I resent that okay but
that's what sound like what you just
three of you said was people got cancer
and they came in and told us they got
cancer from p no some of us actually
looked into stuff okay
but the issue is where if you looked at
the stuff you could answer my simple
question
show me a product that's in the
Hampshire right now that's going to give
you cancer and I'm just saying to you is
I have no problem passing this
legislation I am more than willing to do
it but I just am very
frustrated that I don't know how to
identify the product the caring house
and and more specifically Mr chairman
more more specifically where's the
peer-reviewed published random IED
control trial that links a to c and that
is not right I mean that's the tricky
part there's there's no doubt in my mind
like representative spear said and we
talked about this previously that
there's a lot of data that P is bad I
don't want it in my water don't
particularly wanted on my carpets or on
my couch either the the question is I
I'm just asking what are these give us
some examples of these nine products and
the best science that we have which
should be a peer reviewed in a high
level data in a high level Journal right
peer-reviewed published randomized
control trial I mean that's
scientifically how you make that
conclusion and no other way it's not
rumor conjecture an anecdotal been
researching there's information out
there okay the federal uh what is it the
FDA published two articles in
peer-reviewed uh toxicology I guess uh
magazines and I don't remember the name
and I I could dig it out for you
peer-reviewed the whole works where they
said that they found that the FDA was
passing products that were in fact
causing
cancer identifiable cancer but you know
what the great I want to know what the
name of the product was I will give you
what's the name of the prod all I'm
asking is for a name diet they said a
bunch of product with no all I'm begging
is tell me theit minute what about
they're all known to cause cancer got
from 3M in laim M and and Dupont they
did probably the best peer-review study
of anybody ever they studied their own
employees for 30
years but they still make de Teflon now
it wasn't Teflon that they were doing at
the time it was like uh the um Scotch
Guard and and things like that which is
why 3M say they're not going to make it
anymore because that Dupont rather
doesn't make has Scotch Guard really
been removed from the product I I don't
I don't know that we don't know I I
don't know that okay but they did that
they did that study okay on their own
employees I heard that yes you did tell
us about that before representa taxon
so going back to the the real question
here is as a piece of
legislation it feels like the right
thing to do but I don't have any
quantifiable information that says it's
the right thing to do that's my problem
period that's it there a lot of emotion
over this which I think is
misplaced okay thank you very much Sarah
thank you and I I wanted to offer I
don't know whether this group has had a
chance to speak with de's toxicologist
Dr patali but if uh the group would be
interested we could make arrangements
for I would say anybody who can tell us
a product that's going to be banned or
just going to be affected by this leg
love to know what it is yeah just love
to know something Scotch Guard is no
longer on the market by the way Scotch
Guard is no longer on the market okay
thank you represent
Ammon okay ask question what say I have
a a question oh for Sarah or or Ken or
either one okay I guess come on yeah so
this is quite an extensive list and I'm
wondering if we can narrow it down to
just the worst offenders and start there
you know like what's the what's the
minimum viable product for a piece of
legislation like this where you know we
we can start with the the worst of it
and then see how that goes and then
maybe adjust our list from there is
there an idea of what that could be um
could I just get the list I mean they
they were all and I want to answer one
of
them
um okay so why don't we
just go to the product ban list and I
just want to if it's okay I want to
start
out um first of all by saying you do
have a letter in support from um um an
epidemiologist at Dartmouth Hitchcock
who uh basically outlined for you the
health um effect
information um in some
detail
um and I can get more Health Data I mean
I don't think that the federal
government or the state would be
requiring testing of pasas to the
trillionth if there wasn't plenty of
peer reviewed data in support of the
problems with pasas I there um endocrine
disruptors there's any number of things
in Minnesota one of the things that uh
prompted the passage of their law was a
young woman who had an unbelievably rare
cancer um that was directly related
proven to P exposure so there's no
question that that you know there are P
issues related to health and you know I
guess we talked so much about the health
effects when we were talking about the
carpets bill before um I didn't bring a
lot more health information in here if
that's something the committee needs we
can certainly do that Jonathan patali is
the toxicologist who is a specialist in
P he could talk for days about this
issue I just there there's just
absolutely no question that P is bad for
your health so the next thing I did
provide to the committee in a packet
when during the original hearing there's
a document from
swana um and it says here where you get
the most exposure directly to p and
that's food packaging Cosmetics dust
from all these products that have P in
them and carpet so that's
this on the co topic of food packaging
if you Google food packaging past you
can come up with any number of things
but just yesterday um thinking about
this question Mr chair I um came across
a consumer reports article which I'd be
happy to provide to you that gave you
very specifics on fast food um
operations and the exact packages that
you don't want to eat from if you go to
an arb's and order a cookie yeah no I
got the consumer report but the consumer
report never use the word past they were
just saying Plastics no the one no
that's really recent there's yeah that's
one I had the recent one it's not that
one there's a previous one yeah so the
other
thing what not sure okay so then the
next thing is landfill leade I also gave
you guys this document and what's in
here is um the places in our waist
stream that carry the biggest loads of
past into the landfills one is bulky
items which is furniture and carpet the
next category is textiles which I've got
here and whoops so it's bulky items
which is Furniture textiles and
Carpeting and that's how this
list that's how this list was developed
um um that so it's very hard for me to
say to you that we should narrow this
list um Vice chair am Ammon because
every single thing that's on here was
very specifically chosen a for the for
the past load B for the um most uh
opportunity for exposure to human beings
and three because it was banned in other
places um so like carpets huge load
children crawl around on them
Cosmetics I mean you're smearing these
things on your face and they have past
in them and so that's on our swana list
textile treatments um because of the
exposure from furniture and from carpets
that's why it's on the list it's just
really bad stuff feminine hygiene
products they've got it in
there and you're applying it directly to
your body I don't really have to go into
more detail food packaging and
containers we're eating out of the
things juvenile
products there's so many past in
products that are being marketed to our
children age 12 and under I can't
imagine removing them
PPE I mean same thing we're sticking all
this stuff on our faces upholstered
furniture has an enormous P load and
we're crawling and sitting on it and
textile Furniture Furnishings again it's
textiles it has a large past load it's
in our contained houses and we're
inhaling it and it generates dust
so I just I understand what you're
saying about narrowing the list there is
not one thing on here that I can say to
you was not really carefully selected
for past load and maximal exposure to
the human
being thank you for that answer yeah I'm
sorry if it was more complete than you
might have liked but uh I want you to
understand I I just want to explain how
these product s got on to this list I'd
be interested you mentioned it sounded
like you were describing a matrix of the
N uh the nine things and they were
banned in other states y um and then you
mentioned a couple other aspects I think
i' like to see that list well you have
the safer I again I distrib the graph
that you mentioned yeah yeah and if you
still have it in your documents um if
not I me it's in my drawer I have it
yeah but I do have a follow question
that's
um could there be um unintended
consequences to the market and I I'm
just trying to imagine a scenario so
let's say we have another pandemic and
it's really severe this time and PPE is
in short supply and some of that PPE has
P um you know associated with it so we
have it it would reduce our supply uh
you know potentially I'm just trying to
think of like um because whenever you
whenever you bring whenever you uh
mandate or ban something in the market
it causes unattended consequences can
you think of anything like that that
might be Rel um the only thing I would
say is in the case of a well first of
all responding directly to your question
about um the pandemic um that would be a
de there would be a declaration of
emergency and then the um and then the
governor could just you know do what he
wants as far as the statutes were
concerned so but there is a anyway go
ahead
um and and then the whole thing about
the unintended consequences so um again
this goes this goes back
to why I was really careful to look at
other targeted bands in other states in
particular in California and how this is
like an evolving thing and um a lot of
the products that I have here are being
banned in other other states and so if
you look at it as sort of a if I think
of it like
dominoes if you have something that's
really horrible and what you're eating
or what you're walking on or sitting on
then you want to get a
concentration of states that are saying
we don't want this stuff anymore please
take it out of our out of Commerce keep
it going
okay so so that's why yeah so I I did we
did some narrowing already we've done a
lot of narrowing we did and I'm my issue
is is that not not withstanding that we
don't in terms of identifying products
we can only asking people in the room
yeah has anybody got a problem with this
do anybody not get an exemption that
they would like to or want an exemption
is everybody in have is it happy in the
room okay all we can do is then say the
legislative process is carrying forward
Ward and there's several more bites at
this apple before it leaves us it's
going to go to I assume I don't know uh
Finance it's go to finance because of
this the appropriation um so it'll let
that'll be and then it's going to go to
the Senate yeah and then and ultimately
the governor and so if there somebody
has a problem they're going to they'll
let the governor know and he'll veto it
and then we can start all over again
next year so at this point um you know I
I I feel that we have narrowed it down
we' solved the problems from the state
from like when Maine did which was
insane because they just simply said
everything without anything without
identifying anything without ning
without doing they just said everything
and and so all hell is broken up there
so the fact that we have this narrow I
think it's going to be almost model
legislation for other states who want to
to to just get their feet wet in this
issue and find out and because it's got
the clearing house piece in it so I'm
I'm I'm willing to to run with it even
though as a republican I I'm I'm like
I'm shaking my head that we're Banning
something that nobody can actually tell
me what we're Banning you know I don't
know what product I'm making disappear
but we'll soon find out if there is a
problem we'll soon find out so you have
another question I can I can skip it
okay represent piselli I had a question
about the implementation and if you've
already covered this then I will
withdraw the question but there is a uh
generic list so I'm not really quite
sure how the actual implementation of
the ban and the
um the followup and the uh how will this
be enforced I just that part I'm not
really quite sure what that's why we'll
we'll hire um somebody at Dees and Dees
has the option um to pass a set of
regulations that will help to put
parameters around it but but quick
follow so okay Cosmetics you ban
Maybelline big lash mascara like who is
taking it off the shelf I just don't
quite understand the mechanics well they
will know I mean do you have a specific
product list with like we have a foure
window and so manufacturers will
be
turn the mic yeah so
um so manufacturers will progressively
be removing P from their cosmetics in
fact in California I mean this bill sets
up an intentionally added past standard
for all these products in California for
Cosmetics you cannot have any past they
have a list a mile long of things you
can no I know so what I was going to say
is that over the course of the next four
years until the ban is implemented the
other thing that's going on is that EPA
is kicking off a required
reporting um thing that shows all the uh
things that have pasas in it and that
will be up and running the reporting
requirements will be up and running by
May of 2025 that's 3 years before our
band can come into place and so we can
be starting to look over the docu the
the items that they've reported on that
have pasas in them and start to narrow
down the um thing but the other thing is
keep in mind this is a bill that puts
the
responsibility not on our retailers but
on the
manufacturers to stop making these items
with P in them and they will be banned
from selling them into the
state so um it's on them and it's not on
our local
people representative Gibbs thank you
um I want I'm wondering uh if you can
tell us um what products or types of
products you considered Banning that you
decided not to ban that you did not put
on this list of nine products yeah I
will be happy to and you can um you know
you're you're welcome to add um I did
not put apparel on here I
think you know actually in in thinking
about it in some ways the way you did
Vice chair um Ammon I didn't I mean this
is big but I didn't want to get into
apparel also people feel really strongly
about the gortex in the state and also
if you're talking about apparel you can
all you can have many exclusions to it
it's just really a complicated area I
also didn't feel like there were enough
states that were diving into that right
off the bat so that was one thing that I
didn't include I didn't include cleaning
products a vast area it includes
Industries hospitals it just seemed
really complicated to me that's
something that Minnesota is working on
right now it could be added at some
later date definitely a problem and then
the other thing that I don't have in
here is
cookware and thank you and the thing is
in
California um as part of their past ban
they didn't ban cookware they had a
labeling requirement for cookware so if
you start seeing cookware labeled for
its past content that's why and they
have a similar law that they passed um
in Colorado labeling requirement
Minnesota um I think you may see as a
result of that you know more and more
cookware coming off the market I
wouldn't touch a Teflon nonstick pan for
all the tea in
China I well I don't know you what you
do is you look and see if they've been
made with past and and that's you know
and then you know like the chair was
asking about
um we were talking about apparel where
in California they're starting to get
rid you know they have a law that says
no pfas and apparel REI is starting to
withdraw all its pasas added uh and so
that's how you start seeing um the
effect of these bands manifested in the
products that you're buying and once the
EPA EPA reporting requirement is up and
running I mean that it will be public
and we can check all kinds of things on
there so we just had pass around a
letter from the professional firefighter
of New Hampshire um so in New Boston we
have the space force station used to be
the Air Force Station and we have a p
problem from the firefighting foam that
they used there for many decades went
into our groundwater so I appreciate the
this letter I don't know where it came
from some it came from me came from I
mean I mean people are like sending
letters to to you or to you or to me and
and um I at some point I want to go sit
with the clerk and make sure everybody
has all the letters we also have an nrdc
letter which I just provided to the
clerk it's filled to the brim with
citations on
epidemiology yeah I mean people
cance has a horrible problem has a
horrible problem and has for years and
it's right and I'm talking to the
firefighters they're really very
concerned and I thought wrote a very
strong
letter right um I guess uh do we want to
continue the subcommittee work session
or do we want to take a break anybody
else anybody
else it so we'll take a five minute oh
representative spear sorry I didn't see
make a
motion oh we're not an executive session
where this is
only you can do a sub commmittee motion
oh we can
okay all to pass on the amendment all to
pass on the amendment okay any
discussion on that motion so the clerk
needs to catch up then I'm sorry I make
the motion to ought to pass on the
amendment sorry I didn't have the
machine
on okay any
discussion okay so who's on this subit
make sure I got it
right I misunderstood I thought to it's
a subcommittee motion yeah it's a
subcommittee motion yeah okay
so yeah okay so I have
Ammon Cole
axon hunt
melier grassie Spear and we're missing
Herbert I gu so
okay all right all right so all those in
favor please say I all right those
opposed okay so the vote
is 5 to
one six seven no seven to one seven to
one
okay all right we're end that
discussion good thank you great job so
we will be executing this on next
Wednesday they stole my
schedule and I guess like Clos the sub
here
what's
next I'm multitasking
here
okay all right Keith the amendment pass
okay so you have one and then here's
next the
only I well when I came back
in
representative Ammon is this the
amendment that you emailed to us it is
this is the ess's draft of what what
it's the same one yeah thank
you um I guess I'll set it up a little
bit
um so this is an amendment for House
Bill
you guys ready okay um so the original
Bill if you remember had three parts to
it and it was it was a big reach um it
had making gold and silver legal tender
it had the state establishing a Boolean
depository and it had an electronic
currency portion to the bill and uh to
me the last two were were the most
interesting this Amendment removes the
Boolean depository and the electronic
currency piece um and what I'm thinking
is in future years those two things
could lend themselves
to a stable coin um uh uh I want to say
regime but that's not the right word a
regulatory system for stable coins which
would include a gold and Sil a gold and
silver stable coin and it could be not
the state but third party so the state
would and we can get into that next term
right so I took that out I think those
two um those two sections are useful for
a future and and a broader discussion
and a a more wellth thought out
discussion but what we did was uh just
remove or just keep the original
language uh of the um of making gold and
silver legal tender we removed a bunch
of definitions that no longer applied
because they're not in the language
anymore um we we put in uh an a
reference to uh some federal statute if
you look on page two line line 11 that
was new that was just to clarify what
what it meant previously and we moved
the effective date out to January 1 it
was it was July so we gave it another
six months um I've since had a
conversation with um Christine
heck um do you want to talk about you
sent us an email last night saying you
were going to look at the bill and I
think you had an additional thought and
maybe we could start there
Katherine I'm getting your name mixed up
I'm
sorry so your concern was about applying
this to municipalities making it
mandatory for municipalities um and and
you had an additional
thought thank you representative Aman A
members of the committee for the record
my name is Katherine heck and I
represent the 234 cities and towns of
New Hampshire and we have been talking
with the sponsor on making sure that
municipality aren't compelled somehow to
use um silver and gold in day-to-day
transactions as we believe that there
would be significant cost internal
controls and a real restructuring of how
local government functions in addition
to a lot of expertise needed and the
sponsor is very willing to um he
appreciates um our concern and has been
working to address those concerns
however when we look at I apologize I've
only seen the amendment on the computer
so I'm trying to and there's a couple
copies over there on the table if uh
anyone needs one when we look at the
amendment it discusses that no person or
persons and let me just find that
section I
apologize um P page two line two page
two line two thank you so much I
appreciate that so specifically no
person should be compelled by another
person to accept legal tender so we are
political subdivisions we are not
persons so again we we've talked about
addressing that concern and maybe
ensuring that political subdivisions
cannot be compelled meaning it would be
a local option not a you know mandate
and in addition uh it discusses that any
taxes paid that are issued by the state
of New Hampshire and that again is
concerning because we collect swept tax
on behalf of the state so it's a state
Levy that we collect on their behalf so
we would just want to make sure that
that it it could be considered that we
are somehow carved out of a compelling
mandate so that we can decide for
ourselves if this is something that
moves forward um in our state that it is
done so at the local level by local
decision making so I think that was our
our comments and our concerns if if we
add that language if if we decide to
move forward with this adding that
language would satisfy your concern yes
it would okay all right and um King do
you have any comments and so now we kind
of had this this is mainly original
language and we had a broad public
hearing about it but now we're just
focusing on this one aspect so I'm sure
you have some thoughts on it I
think oh I'm sorry somebody had a
question uh representative
Gibbs uh excuse me uh sorry could you
tell me where we would find that um
provision that no one would be required
to accept or silver yeah so page two
line two on the amendment I I I'm sorry
I can't hear you page two line two on
the amendment is it says uh A person
shall not compel another person and you
would add um a political subdivision yes
yeah okay thank you and that that was uh
at lunchtime we talked about that so
thank you thank
you and then uh Jean from the
Dr
good afternoon Representatives um my
name is Keen mang Wong tax policy
council with the New Hampshire
Department of Revenue uh thank you very
much uh representative Ammon for
forwarding the uh copy of the amendment
to us uh I only managed to read it this
morning uh and we quickly um had some
identified certain concerns uh with with
this uh specific
Amendment okay
see so first off um I think I think it's
quite obvious that uh this is uh
something new for the Dr to uh to to
work on
uh uh accepting or or looking at uh
returns with uh that's not in US dollars
so whether it's in it's in different
um different function functional
currency or different legal tender um so
I think the first concern that we had
was um all our tax laws in New Hampshire
all the amounts the thresholds um that's
report that's used in in our tax act New
Hampshire Tax Act are all using US
dollars so um if the currency that's
being used uh by these qualified
business units are in a different
different functional currency um and if
they're reporting uh on their returns in
a different functional currency um so I
think the the concern is how what kind
of exchange rate would be used to
translate that into uh to see if if
certain thresholds for certain
deductions and things like that or
taxability uh would be considered when
uh reporting the return I I guess um
because the one of the language in the
bill is that the um the taxpayer is
allowed the option to actually pay tax
or even report their return in a in a
different functional currency than US
Dollars and and only they would only
convert that to US dollars if they like
to pay taxes in US dollars so um I I
think that's one of the concerns that we
have how would that look like we're not
really sure but something that we want
to raise to make sure that the committee
is aware of that um the other thing is
that um let's say if we were going to be
looking at the books of certain
taxpayers who are using a different
functional currency um than a US dollar
uh we're not really sure how their books
would look like um if they're using gold
um how how would a book how how would
their accounting records look like in
terms of reporting of of of their
journal entries in terms of um some the
transactions in in gold or in silver in
other precious metal um so that's also
another thing that that we we're sort of
not sure but but um so I just want to
raise that um and regards to functional
currency so yes um the qualified
business units are allowed to uh keep
their books and Records in a different
functional
currency
um granted that functional currency is
not really defined in this amended bill
but I would take it take that to assume
the functional currency would include um
these different legal tender um that is
um defined here in in the 5D colon 2 um
like speci legal tender um
bullion um and things like that um
another item is
that oh so for um for business taxes for
business profits tax purposes um
business taxpayers are are able to file
a combined return so if um if a meaning
to say that if a a a
tax a business organization they have uh
different um divisions or different
business units um and and they are or or
different different
subsidiaries they similar like similar
to like a federal Consolidated return
but this is for New Hampshire side it's
not a consolid return is a combined
return so the concepts of combined
filing uh is applied here so then we're
we're thinking if um if this group of
taxpayers has one qualified business
unit that's using a different currency
uh that which is a legal tender New
Hampshire legal tender currency which is
not US Dollars and then um and then
another part of this group is using US
Dollars and then when they file their
return they're required to follow if
they they if they meet the requirements
of um of unitary if they're unitary then
they need to file a combined return one
return uh to the New Hampshire
Department of Revenue then how would
that return look like if they if one of
the qbus decide to say okay we're going
to pay our taxes in a different currency
whereas the rest of the group say okay
they want a US dollars so this is
probably some something internal that
they would decide themselves however um
so that's one thing that we were
thinking okay how would that look like
if they want to do that that's the
that's the ability
for the um for those business units to
make that decision that way and if it
serves their business purpose to do it
that way then um currently our our
structure is not catered to that we only
reporting everything in in one US dollar
um the the other concern is the um the
no tax implication from converting um
one legal tender to another legal tender
or purchasing um purchasing or sale of
uh booon when not giving rise not give
rise to tax
liability um maybe potentially if that
language could be narrowed down to
potentially just for reporting purposes
versus the say if the taxpayer was to be
investing in Boolean um and then so when
when the price is low they purchase a
whole bunch of booon and when the price
is high convert that to a different like
a US dollar currency and then gaining
some kind of um
uh exchange gain in that sense um and if
that's that's kind of a business
activity we think that probably should
be taxable um of course this is a policy
concern if if the if the committee feels
that okay those kind of transactions are
still not taxable but then I we just
think that maybe if if we were to um so
there kind of like a speculation at play
here here where people just Pro probably
play the Commodities market and stuff
like that um so um I'm not sure that's
something that's um considered by the by
the committee um and then finally it's
also the cost involved as uh that's what
Katherine he had mentioned if um if
taxpayers were to start paying their
taxes in uh something other than US
dollars as if they're using spey gold or
spey silver or bu on um there would be
definitely some cost involved for
infrastructure for Dr to accept those
kinds of precious metals and security
infrastructure how to maintain that um
and uh so th those are generally our
concerns with this they sound like Val
valid concerns to me U questions over
here I'll start with representative mler
um thank you um the first thing that
well you started talking about but the
first thing that jumped
out to me on this bill is is again line
one page two I have no idea how this
would not be subject to uh short-term
long-term capital gains or losses um I
just don't understand it because it's in
fact it would be the same thing as if
I'm you know trading International
currencies and if I've got gains I pay a
tax on them so that was the first thing
the second thing which is actually my
first question is I just don't
understand the practicality of this at
all I I just don't see that it's it's
needed that it's necessary um maybe uh
representative Ammon can address this
but what is really the purpose of this I
don't get it thank you I think the uh
the the purpose of this bill I it's more
of a policy question and I I'm not in
any position to address that that that
question okay yeah represent Gibbs thank
you um my questions are actually for you
representative em and um and just I I
just need to back up a little bit
uh to be sure I understand correctly if
I am an owner um or an employee of a
business who needs to have a bill paid
or I am a tax collector at any level of
government in New Hampshire state or
local and so somebody comes to me and
says I want to pay my bill or my taxes
in gold or
silver under this bill I could say no
the payment must be in dollars is that
correct that's correct I so that's the
next line on page two line two I just
wanted to be sure of that mutually
agreed upon I I'm sorry it would have to
be mutual okay um and then um I guess my
my other question is um going along with
repes representative melier and that's
basically why we have um currency in
this country uh the dollar which has a
full faith and credit of the United
States government um and what I don't
understand is why we need anything
else you want to know the answer to that
um okay so um we're not we're not the
only state considering this there about
10 states that have done this already um
and it it ties in with the US
Constitution and it's referenc in the
bill it's article uh one section 10 and
it talks about um no State shall and
then there's a list of things in it says
so no no State shall dot dot dot make
anything but gold or silver coin a
tender in payment of debts so so that
the state has the ability to to uh
follow the to uh
explicitly enact that I wasn't asking
why we can do it I understand what you
just said that's the foundation I was
asking why would we want to do it uh do
you want to know the answer or do you
want to ask questions um question yeah
yeah okay so this is my personal feeling
um the the inflation that we've gone
through and we've gone through several
periods of inflation uh that it might
make sense to have sort of like an alter
alternative that's based on
constitutional principles um that maybe
only a few people will use but um we
have a mechanism for uh avoiding a
significant inflation event um you know
so this gets into representative maer's
question last week about you know is
this a
philosophical uh
discussion the this is my opinion the
national debt in the beginning of this
year just a few weeks ago past $34
trillion um the interest on that debt is
approaching $800 billion that's as much
as we spend on defense and the
projection is that it could get
hyperbolic at some point right so this
is sort of like a um a
precaution uh and you know maybe you
don't agree with that but there are
people there are people in my town that
that would like to be able to do this so
um you know it's it's it's it's
voluntary but it's a a way to uh use
another currency as legal tender but is
there anything that currently prevents
any individual from keeping gold either
gold coins or gold bullion for any
purpose either as a hedge against
inflation or for instance as my father
did as a protection in case God forbid
another Hitler were to arise and we had
to have something that we could pick up
and and carry across the border
in desperation as he and his parents had
to do in in in in
1938 uh there's so far as I know there's
nothing in the current law that prevents
you from doing that right so you can
hold gold uh in your possession of
course that's no but this is uh there's
no prohibition against that but this is
for transactional purposes right so this
is to sort of make it a a part of the
economy in a very small way for people
that want to do it that that's my best
explanation representative txon
so and I I'm really going to try and not
go down the economic Rabbit Hole
here the 6:1 ratio called out for in the
Constitution never worked and was always
a problem and that's
been covered in numerous different
places of subsequent
legislation economic changes the Federal
Reserve Act the the uh taking the United
States off the gold standard making the
dollar non-convertible all of those
things while they're fascinating to
people like me are probably outside the
scope of what anyone in this room wants
to deal with right now so the it seems
to me that the point of this bill is to
achieve something which already exists
in the
marketplace if I have a box full of
Krueger rans and I want to buy your
house with that box full of Krueger
Rands and that works for you under New
Hampshire law we have something called a
barter and sale
deed I can you can that's a legal
transaction Y and that transaction for
reporting purposes Department of Revenue
Annihilation would be to say What's the
value of those that box of Krueger RS at
today's gold price and that's the
transfer we pay the transfer tax off of
that in United States
dollars
this the the problem of
inflation of the United States dollar
which has been more or less continuous
since
1795 again for a whole lot of
interesting and not relevant
reasons
uh would
be you're you're trying yeah it's a
concern it's a concern for all of us but
this isn't the fix on it so if I have a
whole box of Krueger RS or if I'm like
representative Gibbs fathers and I need
to have an emergency slush fund which I
understand that
completely that's not that's outside the
scope of this bill I need that's a
tangible asset something that's
convertible or something I can trade
with it could be diamonds it could be
gold it could be Krueger RS it could be
barold and then after the change in the
law in the GRE Administration we're now
allowed to own gold as American citizens
which we were barred from
previously so other than the fact that
I'm going to go I have a box full of
Krueger RS and I want to pay my
$76,000 tax bill to the town of Troy
because it's a good day to sell
gold uh I can take that and sell it on
the open market and then bring those
dollars and go pay the tax collector I
would point out to you and I don't know
who somebody testified on behalf of the
tax collectors if you're not aware of it
it is illegal for any tax collector in
the state of New Hampshire to have more
than $1,500 in a safe
overnight so I don't know where you guys
live but that doesn't even cover one
person's tax
bill uh so the practicality of
maintaining gold if you're going to mess
with this stuff you're going to have to
look at a whole lot of other things and
limits that we have set up in our
statutes besides Krueger rants because
there's no Bank in the United United
States that's going to let you walk in
and have and give them $76,000 worth of
gold pieces and say gez thanks we were
hoping somebody would do this
today yeah so cougar I don't think would
be covered by The Spill but I get your
point
um I use krugger as an easily
understandable example of gold coins I'm
sure you do do you have anything to add
uh no that's that's it for okay thank
you very much um uh can you WOTE off on
questions just for now um I want to um
Jim you want to come up uh I just want
to introduce you to Jim forsight he's a
former state senator some of you know
him and he wanted to testify in the
original hearing uh but his wife had a
health condition that prevented him from
coming so he's here and I you know we'll
give you a few minutes Jim and and then
maybe some questions for you yeah of
course and me too and you
too put your mic on please and introduce
yourself for the record all right so I'm
uh James for I or Jim for scye um uh
first thank you uh Vice chair Ammon for
for letting me speak and uh you know
being understanding about my wife's
issues and that's that's actually part
of the reasons why we simplified this
bill for this year um you pull right up
to your your face yeah that's part of
the reason why we simplified this bill
um is I haven't been able to come up
here and put the time needed in into it
because of that but um first I want to
say uh I registered yesterday as a
lobbyist um just yeah I I haven't it
takes time to make the tags and I
apologize for that but I I am registered
as a lobbyist um I I'll give you some
quick background on myself only so you
understand I am not dick marpel um for
those you know may you rest in peace um
so Air Force veteran I was a KC 135
pilot um flew out of Saudi Arabia um
then I got my PhD and taught at the Air
Force Academy um was a business owner
for a while wound up working civil
service in the Navy um and the last
several years when I saw all the kind of
macro events
unfolding um I thought it was time to
start doing something about what I think
I see is coming which is you know a
dollar crisis I'll put it that way um
and because our debt to GDP is 140% if
you look at history uh Any Nation that's
hit that number n it's over 95% have
defaulted um now that doesn't mean they
default uh by not paying people back for
their bonds but it's they inflate the
currency so and keep the rates down so
that they can do a default a soft
default via inflation that happened
after World War II that's how we paid
for World War II is we we uh screwed
over the bond holders um and I I don't
want that to happen to people in New
Hampshire or this country and I I you
know the federal government's not going
to change this because they benefit from
this it allows them to spend like crazy
um but the States you know are far more
responsible so that's why we're working
on this legislation
um I am the chair of citizens for sound
money it's a
501c4 uh by our by laws the majority of
the board has to be outside the precious
metals industry so we are not
representing um precious metal vendors
we work with them and communicate with
them we we're representing consumers uh
and also business owners that want to
use this in their
business um represent am talked about
the original Bill uh so I'll stick to uh
you know the amendment I will point out
that uh there's similar l language uh
legal tender speci language in uh seven
states Utah Oklahoma Arizona Wyoming um
Utah was the first pass it in
2011 um also Arkansas recently and then
there's two states that my understanding
is have had it since the 1800s they just
didn't pull it off the books uh Colorado
and
Missouri
um so
uh so big discussion here is you know is
this needed
um there's there's a couple couple
things first off um if you look at USC
486 left my phone but but it basically
says that if you have a gold or silver
coin and you are you know trying to pass
that off as money um that you can be
fined or impr prisoned and and and one
one person one company was in prisoned
for five years I believe um for doing
that and it says unless otherwise
authorized by law and that's what this
bill is about is authorizing it by law
now um the bill right now only says us
gold and silver coins are legal tender
um then it says the treasury can add
some and that's why I understand the
concerns of Dr in this um and but but
because of because right now it's just
gold and silver eagles that are legal
tender by the statute um I don't think
it's going to be something that is
exercised um because if you if you look
at a gold eagle face value of $50 who's
going to use that exchange rate to pay
taxes okay so so the the payment of
taxes portion I would say is symbolic
it's something that says the state
recognizes this as money um whether or
not the state collects any taxes
currently is not important um to us
anyway but but the state saying that
this is money is important and you know
imagine the chilling effect when you see
somebody's been arrested for they made a
it's not called a coin because only
Sovereign um can make coins it's a round
but you make one and you you try to
spend that and um you know the company
that was making these they did other
things wrong but they got convicted of
uh convicted of under USC 486 and that's
a big chilling effect on business so
that also addresses you say well you can
barter uh that that is true but because
of USC 46 you are placing placing
yourself at risk and that has a chilling
effect on businesses trying to use this
as uh as money
um let's see I I just made some random
notes as people were talking uh so the
the the really only use case given that
right in in the bill as it stands it's
gold and silver eagles the only use case
where anybody would have anybody not
crazy would want to pay their taxes is
if if they use that language that's in
there about um about keep your books in
that currency and uh we put the
reference to the federal statute that's
in there because it's very common
practices for companies using foreign
currencies and we're just modeling okay
how could you have a system where you
have gold currency but you also have US
dollar currency side by side and and so
the federal statutes cover that that
well and there's some details in there
uh to provide guidance
um uh someone brought up federal capital
gains this this bill is about the state
of New Hampshire so us saying it's not
taxable doesn't mean that I I understand
the concern about if it's a business uh
doing it as capital gains but again if
you're viewing this as money which it
should be it is not a gain it is a
preservation of your purchasing power
gold hasn't gone from $40 to
$2,000 it hasn't gained that much more
value it's actually if you look at a
chart of oil over the last 100 years
it's got ups and downs but it's flat the
US dollar meanwhile has gone like this
the dollar cost of oil so it's not a
capital gains it is a a preservation of
your purchasing
power
um why wouldn't need anything from the
other dollars because it's the full
faith and credit of the US government
well I explained that debt to GDP of
140% so not all of us have faith in the
United States government I have far more
faith in the New Hampshire
government
um represent was talking about something
where we kind of provide a framework for
stable coins I I think that's an
excellent idea um some of those may not
be what I would consider sound money but
eager to work with people on that we
think people should have multiple
options for currencies people overseas
are very used to this you know what
currency am I going to hold here we just
hey it's the US dollar it's the best in
the world it has been but that that time
is I think dangerously coming close to
an end and you don't pass this bill um
you know two years later you may really
wish you had but again this is is laying
the foundation for what we actually want
to do because you know gold and silver
eagles is currency is not really
practical but we want to lay the
foundation for um legal tender species
including products other than those um
gold backs are beautiful but then also
layering on top of that a digital
currency you know on the blockchain that
is audited um insured one to one and uh
so and that part of the feed that back
we got about the state depository in the
electronic currency we took that to
heart the complexity of it the the
capital investment and so we're leaning
more towards uh doing something like
electronic currencies through a
framework like representative Ammon says
where it's not the state currency it's a
private currency but there's a
regulatory framework that makes sure
that New Hampshire residents are safe
because there's going to be a lot of
scams in this
so thank you will you take questions
sure all right uh representative spear
I'm sure has a question for you
or statement my question isn't really it
it could be directed to either one of
you I guess so we've talk I'll address
it to you
yeah I don't like evaluating this based
on a philosophy that the United States
government's going to collapse or or any
of those things I I I can't do that I
don't have the ability to do that so
what I did was I went and looked to find
out why are states doing it this is and
and not anything more complicated than
what's in this bill just within this
framework
okay so I look around and I found 13
states some of which you've named and I
have a list of the others and then I
started looking at their bills and I
started looking and this was tedious and
I ran out of time after about four or
five
hours in every in every
case it was a tax
avoidance effort in every case it was
quoted as I don't have to pay sales tax
on gold and I don't have to pay Capital
Gains state level capital gains tax on
gold and I don't have to pay intangible
tax on gold uh increasing at the state
level at the state level you still have
to pay it on the federal level you can't
get away from that and unfortunately
because the IRS recognizes which states
do it they look at them pretty pretty
closely another
issue across those 13 states I made a
little
Matrix and every one of them have a mix
of capital gains tax sales tax income
tax and tangible
tax every one of them we have none of
that so we don't get any of the benefit
of why these other states were doing it
we don't pay any of these taxes we have
a vague in tangible tax interest in div
ends but that's being phased out we
don't pay a capital gains tax we don't
pay a sales tax we're not getting a
benefit or at least as the reasons these
states said they were doing
it okay so I I'm not clear after that it
just becomes an emotional
thing you want to respon to that um well
I I would
certainly calling a question calling it
tax avoidance um you know if you have
$100 and you shove it under your
mattress you don't pay taxes on it the
only reason that gold goes up in dollar
terms is because they're inflating the
currency so it's not a it's it's not a
capital game no I I I'm not I'm not
implying an avoidance I'm just saying
that's what the reasons they were giving
is though they didn't have to pay those
taxes understood yeah and so so there is
the one clause in the the Clauses in the
bill that speak to taxes in New
Hampshire are largely irrelevant I agree
um but business profits tax is not one
of them if you wanted to operate your
business business uh using gold and
silver right now you'd wind up paying a
big uh profit from that that you know
from the gold and silver you're holding
as it goes up in value as the dollar
inflates um so so it does have some
impact in New Hampshire because it would
allow for businesses to operate with a
gold and silver as their you know their
their money um without having to be
subject to taxes based on on that
um but it it's actually kind of a good
good point because yeah there may there
may be motivations tax-wise in a lot of
other states um so you know this bill is
in New Hampshire geared more towards
philosophical but it's also as I said no
state has passed um something allowing
blockchain gold and Silver's currency
that really is the solution um for for
People Like Us concerned about the
strength of the US dollar that is going
to be the solution um unfortunately it's
fairly complicated we couldn't tackle it
all this year so we want to continue
that discussion next year but um this
lays that the foundation for that you
want to take over um oh I do want to
clarify I I I did not mean to infer
collapse of the US government and I
agree with you I don't want to go there
I don't want that to happen I don't
think that's going to happen I'm talking
strictly about the currency and it may
not be a hard collapse of the currency
but um you know High rates of inflation
with low yields for bonds are going to
wipe out a lot of Pension funds and it's
going to cause it can cause a lot of
Calamity so that's that's my concern not
a collapse of the
government okay representative
zon well first of all I want to thank
you for your service in the military and
I know you hear that a lot and I know
you're a smart guy and good at what you
do if you taught at the Air Force
Academy and I appreciate all those
things and God knows served as a state
senator in New Hampshire for your
hundred bucks a year which has got to be
way more fun in this
job but you really let the cat out of
the bag and earlier in your statements
and you've backtracked on it which is
respectable and understandable but what
this bill is really about is a lack of
faith in the government of the United
States ability to manage its
finances that's what we're really
talking about that's pretty much and on
the one hand I recognize that there are
issues I can certainly see in
econom in terms of economic history and
look down the pipeline and go it could
go this way it could go that way I
certainly do not support a list way too
long to get into in this room for things
that happened or happening in
Washington at the end of the day for the
New Hampshire
legislature to agree to this I think
only serves to further undermine the
full faith and credit of the United
States and I can't do
that that's it as um I I I appreciate
the question um I I think the way you're
phrasing is is good it's it's it's
demonstrating some skepticism let me put
it that way of the US government to
handle its finances I think that's 100%
accurate and that's kind of what this
bill is doing as a statement we're
concerned about you guys handling your
finances I hope that working with
represent of Ammon um on a blockchain
gold we can come up we can have a
solution in New New Hampshire for that
to provide people an alternative so I
think that's fair I honestly disagree
though say you saying you know I can't
go there like I am a veteran and um I
think it's our duty to go there to say
we don't trust what you guys are doing
with your finances we're going to come
up with an alternative and for all 50
states to do this because the federal
government is not going to do it they
cannot they cannot break the promises
they made with Social Security they
can't they can't they can't stop um and
it's going to take a crisis for them to
change and that crisis is cause going to
cause pain and suffering my sincere
desire is to stop that pain and
suffering and that's why we're pushing
legislation like this in in as many
states as we
can I think it's our duty not something
that we should be ashamed about um I I
have question a lot of foreign military
involvement that does doesn't mean I'm
unpatriotic that means I care about the
veterans okay thank you representa Gibbs
thank you um I'm not going to try and
argue the large issues with you because
I think you and I just don't see the
world the same way and there's no chance
that we would ever agree but I have a
very specific question on the
information that you provided earlier
you were talking about a federal law
that makes it a crime to present
I believe to present he's getting
sorry okay but let me finish my question
yes um yeah you're talking about a
federal law that makes it a crime to
present gold as money and you referenced
someone who was convicted and uh went to
jail for 5 years and then a little bit
later you said a company was convicted
um and companies can be convicted of
crimes but they don't go to jail so my
question is which was it a person or a
company so it was uh Bernard barnat
House of the liberty dollar um it's
actually and I you know I was big into
the gold and silver movement and I
didn't like what I saw from that um
so the the case hearing for that is
actually really really good in terms of
what they looked at and they looked at
USC
486 the questional of it was called into
question by uh Gata the gold antitrust
ass Association unfortunately the court
did not rule on the constitutionality of
this statute because he also um like he
would do stuff like go to the store and
drop a coin into someone's hand and he
he basically he really tried to pass it
off as as US
currency and so USC 486 wasn't um called
in the constitutionality wasn't called
into question even though it was
challenged but but what it says is
whoever except as authorized by law La
makes or utters or passes or attempts to
utter or pass any coins of gold or
silver or other metal or Alloys metal
intended for use as current money with
in the resemblance of us United States
or foreign countries or of original
design shall be find under this title or
imprison not more than five years or
both so in other words if I have a
silver Buffalo round and and I go to try
to spend it as money I can go to prison
for five years will that happen probably
not but it's on the books could you
speak into could you speak into the mic
please yeah so so my example is if
someone takes a you know a a buffalo and
takes it to the store and tries and you
know tries to spend it even if the other
person understands what it is and
accepts it uh by this statute they could
be in prison for five years um and I
think that's an
issue I collect coins and as a result of
that I have a pot load of those Liberty
coins uh they made every effort to make
them look like they were real coins
absolutely yeah I think that was the
core of where this whole thing went
wrong the guy it was like a counterfeit
coin that's that's exactly right so USC
is that was a big discussion in the
courts is is this constitutional and
basically said well you know you there's
a well- established right to barter
which we've talked about you know so
someone should be able to spend these
coins it was challenged constitutionally
but in the end there was definitely a
very counterfeit component to what he
was doing and so they did not rule on
whether 486 was constitutional or not
but under 46 and he you
know I so he went to prison for
counterfeiting not for using gold never
was in silver it was silver well Define
counterfit if I have a a buffalo well if
the co if the court defined it as
counter fitting it was counter
fitting I'm I'm little don't understand
how this has has anything to do with
what we're looking at here I I think
they're diving into the necessity for
this and I I brought your necessity was
that there's another sentence it says
unless the state creat so unless
authorized by law this and this says
except as authorized by law this statute
does that um or this this bill would do
that and it would provide some
confidence for people that that's your
rationale for us that we can pass this
bill and not we be worried about the
feds because this federal law allows no
we don't we're not we don't have to be
worried about the feds because of of you
know over a 100 Years of constitutional
court cases um you know Lane uh the lane
case back in the 1860s says states have
a right to determine what is legal
tender as long as it's gold or silver
states have that right that's been well
established that's not the question the
question is why do we need this and USC
486 is a part of why we need this I
think we also need it because you know
um as a sign that the state recognizes
is gold and silver is still money it is
a good way to preserve your purchasing
power and um and we're concerned about
the federal government overspending and
causing a crisis with our
currency excuse me by gold correct but
if if you're going to use gold like if
you want to have your business start
using gold which you know PE people are
trying to do no I think they're just
saying that they're going to stash away
gold yes for when the crisis occurs yes
that is a when the world comes to an end
that they get their their room full of
gold and they're they're they're feeling
okay okay let's can we wrap this up I
will wrap it
up right I don't know representative giz
has her hand up were you gonna she's
only raising her hand up about five
times and spoken out of turn I think if
well it's not never
mind this is a subcommittee this is a
subcommittee we're not you can talk out
of order so yes go ahead and I'm
subcommittee too yeah yes what would you
like to say never mind I'm just going to
drop it no we want to hear it yeah I
want to hear it well fine it's a
political
statement and what you what you're
saying basically is uh you're you're
worried about inflation and you're
worried about inflation and and that's
based on the I thought he was worried
about the the the the national debt no
no you're you're you're almost there the
worry about inflation goes right back to
the national debt goes right back to the
national debt okay now if you were to go
back and not pass Reagan's tax bill if
you were to go back and not pass George
W Bush's pass Bill if you're to go back
and not P pass Trump's tax bill you
would have a very very small deficit the
problem is is there's two sides to the
deficit one side is spending money and
one side is raising money and that's
what we fail to do and that's why we
have a deficit thank you actually I'm
glad you brought that point up to be
honest um because that gets into
partisanship to be clear I am not
blaming one or the other party for
what's going on in DC it has been both
you've highlighted a lot of parts of
that it has been both um it's also you
know fairly structural I mean it goes
back a long ways the creation of the
Federal Reserve has enabled us this is I
am this is this should not be a
Republican or Democrat issue it's a DC
versus a state issue in my
opinion thank
you and I say that despite my party
affiliation which I went and got when I
decided I was going to run
so yeah so what I think clearly this has
been a very engaging discussion the
committee so so I I think an interim
study motion is is
appropriate okay representative taxon
seconded by representative C moves uh
moves interim study and is there a way
to narrow it just to the amendment um
yeah it's it's the bill number so yeah
it can but in terms of the conversation
we can we when we take it up again we
could certainly say that stick to the
the narrow the narrow subject because it
it certainly we can get our arms around
it more than the big bill so interim
study what I would like to get out of it
I know maybe some people's eyes Glu is
over on this topic but I'm I'm very
interested yeah I'm very interested but
um what the Dr presented uh today maybe
in our interm study focusing just on
this limited Amendment we could dig into
a little more about how would we
implement it at at the diary level I'd
be interested in you know just kind of
learning more so but that narrow subject
you you didn't really have did you have
an opinion on that only only in the
sense that someone was going to try to
pay ax tax bill with it right but isn't
there another side to that I mean what
happens when the state wants to use that
gold to buy the goods and services
convers let's no is that I think it's
the same side that's for the interim
study we have a pending motion this is
discussion right now we're in we're in
discussion on the pending motion wants
to okay all
right thank
you okay we have we have uh um a motion
U to interim study the bill uh obviously
represent Amon opened up a little bit of
a can where I'm saying can we make sure
that the discussion is only around just
the amendment not the whole bill and
that certainly can be possible when we
take up this uh bill um when we uh this
next September okay so is the motion
clear interim study all those in favor
say
I four five six all those opposed I'm
GNA I'm going to post just because
what what you didn't you made the motion
no no oh that's right than made the
motion okay 7 to One S to One 7 to
one what's
that well we still have time to work on
this amendment and maybe we could get
something across the finish line but you
know it's the will of the
committee I I'm uh I'm uh I'm willing to
go along with the will of committee but
okay all right
right on the on the partis side we would
talk about how a couple of budgets were
pass under Biden that uh certainly added
to the
deficit if you want to talk about
partisan stuff okay so last but not
least all right is
our resolu condo
dispute
the Fun's
over
okay it's only 3
o' okay we have done this longer
yeah okay ribbons and elme you want to
tell us about your Amendment
here now you have already seen if you
bothered to read it yet the uh one that
I had in in red red letters in between
that I just wrote up myself and
distributed to everybody at the hearing
um this it is different in one way I
discovered when I went to talk with
oplc that there is no way they would
want us or we would want
them as a home for for the board that
we're trying to get and uh they they
wanted said that if they got it they
would have to license everything the
only only thing to licens is the
property managers there are only a few
of and they'd probably fight back quite
hard uh and it wouldn't do much good
just to license them so um so I uh tried
a couple of other places the housing
appeals board is too new to take
anything on an attachment but uh Das as
a whole has agreed to uh take on the
board as an attached board they have
four others still now that the the
housing appeals board left uh to become
its own
unit and it costs more to become your
own unit
um this um so the last part of this
amendment is
um line 7 to
23 of page
two and and
that is a um putting it in
administrative services and providing an
appropriation from labor grade 19 which
I actually don't know if is too high or
not because that came from opls it's
they had asked for four Personnel three
of whom were highlevel investigators and
lawyers uh and a administrator who would
be labor board 19 I don't know if you
can do with labor board 17 I don't know
anything about these things so I I would
hope that at if this passed that at some
point someone would change that to
whatever is appropriate since it is an
early bill because of the oplc request
for 300
something, uh labor board 19 labor grade
19 for their uh from their perspective
costs 80,000 which is about what we'd
been calculating last term it would cost
to get but we were looking at a a
administrator who would only do certain
tasks that I'd forgotten are also in
this
amendment uh
specifying
um
specifying somewhere oh I I think they
were in what I was just talking
about
um specifying that the board
administrator this is on page two lines
9 to 12 um the board of the de
Department of administrative Services
shall assign a board administrator to
receive complaints forward them to the
board file minutes and reports and place
the Certified Abstract of each final
decision on a public website created for
the purpose and and then the department
shall maintain the
records um that is all that this board
would need in the way of
money and it comes to maybe
$80,000 a year so um that's a lot
different from
what OPC was asking for but they were
contemplating taking over the entire
process and not even they didn't need a
board H did you say was taking over
what's the well office of professional
yes professional lure and certification
they were not I thought you took them
out we did I did take them I that's what
I'm trying who is who is now going to be
the administrator of this program uh
administrative Services Department
administrative Services yes and I've got
that from the head of the department and
who's
that you're talking to someone who
forgets the name of her own sister when
she's asked a question well you know you
know who he's been there a long time
right that's I assume it must be
right
I'm I'm sorry at this point uh I've had
office of administrative Services said
that they're more than welcome to
they're more than to take on yeah and
they have a hearings officer and the and
the Deputy Commissioner and um the woman
who sent it for them said and so this
this is that people pay $500 to come in
and tell their Horror Story to the about
their condo uh well this is within a
specific the way the model that we're
working from worked was that people
would send something
to to the board administrator the board
administrator would look at them and if
it had absolutely nothing to do with
governance or
voting or um getting the minutes done on
time not even getting a minute well
unless you consider that governance but
they they would wipe out any any pink
flamingos and then they would send the
packet to the board and the board meets
and it looks through the packet and it
decides no we've already done minutes on
time and throws that one out and um and
then comes across another one in which
uh they haven't had an election in the
last 10
years for the
board and decides that maybe they'll
take that
one and so they're going to look filing
or someone pays the $500 first or yes
they pay the $500 still that check is
sitting there and the check gets cash
and then they can decide whether they
want to take on the case or not right
and then theoretically they could say no
and the person's out $500s yes exactly
and that's partly to keep out the Pink
Flamingos but it's partly also because P
flamingos government kind of wants more
money to go in for things like this so
it would cost less than 80,000 in the
end so who are these people who are
going to be making this is who's this
board uh so I have to look in the
original Bill the board was in the
original bill
right uh that one would be by the
governor uh they're almost all got by
the governor actually two members of the
House of Representatives appointed by
the speaker three members appointed by
the governor who are resident owners of
condominiums in um New Hampshire and
three from different executive I I have
modified that statement to specify
resident owner unit owners of
condominium so they aren't resident
owners of condom the whole
condominium right uh and that said
neither members jury of the PE peers
because these are just no well that's
just part of it then two members
appointed by the governor who are
members of a Condominium Association
board and from different executive
council districts one member appointed
by the governor who represents a
Condominium Association Management
Company um from a list of three persons
from the community association's
Institute one member and one member of
the New Hampshire Bar Association
appointed by the president of
Association how many board members do we
have all
total five seven nine that's what I
thought it
was it's nine they wouldn't all show up
each time
presumably
but right well like the med panel most
most of these usually just three people
nine seems like a humongous crowd but
okay well it gives you the opportunity
when you've got three people who aren't
being paid if you if one of them doesn't
show up you're in trouble if two of them
don't show up you're dead well no I'm
not even thinking you're you're you're
going to be agreed upon that the three
people are pointed are the ones are
going to show up yeah and that's like
that's the med panel that I was that I
was involved so the thing that bus me
the most about this amendment is on page
two right at the
top in the event either party TRS to
subbly F challenging the final decision
the count such right shall not be
infringed and the board shall be
represented by the Department of Justice
that was well actually that's a hybrid
uh the first part of that was asked of
Me by the head of the consumer
protection
board the second part of it I
added but I am also here before you
trying to get another week so that I can
go back and talk with the the person who
has replaced the head of the consumer
protection board who is on leave for two
months all of a sudden uh with um on go
through the things that he said here
Brandon yeah Brandon Brandon he's on
he's on on leave for he's on leave for I
think it's two months Family Leave yeah
could be I don't know I hadn't known he
was going to but it may be why he called
me up on a Sunday okay now I remember it
wasn't that paragraph which is that
pretty it's pretty outrageous too but it
was the one before it in the event that
the decision the cond dispute resol is
disregarded by one of the
parties okay now this isn't surprise to
me because I'm you know I'm assuming
that that that's going to be the condo
association itself yes is going to say
this is they don't play after C file
with the court the gree May appeal to
the court for
enforcement okay now I thought the whole
point of this thing was so that we could
avoid going to Superior Court the whole
point of it was to try to get to a try
to avoid going to Superior Court but
when they do go to Superior Court there
are decisions of the that board that the
judge can depend on because most of the
judges have a really hard time dealing
with
Condominiums which shouldn't surprise
you either I yeah because
it's can we interim study this bill and
you can work on it and you can bring it
back next
year you promise I can bring it back
next year what's that if you're chair
can you promise I can bring it back you
always bring it back next year doesn't
mean I'll pass said but you know
bringing it back but it feels like you
realize how often we have the the the
bill before I started amending it with
um the various parties that I've just
named yeah on on was the bill that Ned
Gordon finished amending in
2020 and what happened to that uh Co we
passed it in the
house uh the I think before we closed
down and were told to go home very
carefully at 5:00 a.m.
yes right and on it we did actually have
a great deal of interest that year in
the senate in passing it but uh the
Senate closed down shortly after we did
and they would have needed a public
hearing I didn't even ask them I knew
they needed a public
here so it
died got it and and that was the
original bill that you put in today uh
that would no the original bill yeah the
original bill I put in how many weeks
ago was it now yeah right
1645 right as introduced as
introduced but uh at that point we
didn't realize they were going to
totally change
oplc so that this couldn't go there the
manufactured housing board had gone
there had been there the whole time and
um and and they shut it down because no
cases you know no cases
occurred that's what I heard but
somebody here was telling me yeah that
somebody came back with a request that
you started up again yes
so I don't know if they're the same
people who were
complaining yes about the New Hampshire
Community Loan
Fund representative Al me last year I
just want to say I admire your tenacity
on this issue you I think uh I served
with you uh I think last term on the in
uh on the uh condominium study committee
oh yeah yeah and I know you've been
working tirelessly on this issue so I I
uh admire your your well I did it took
me 11 years to get prevention and
treatment along with with representative
Welsh and representative th on into the
drunk driving laws and rationalize the
drunk driving laws that was a joint
effort
though and in this case every every year
new people come on the study committee
which is going away next next year now
um so everybody will be calling
me since there won't be anybody left to
call
Will you're here he's got some
institutional knowledge now
right yeah but his name isn't quite as
well known in condo
circles at this point I thought I fix
that problem if we stayed if we stayed
together longer maybe it would
be but the Attorney General's office for
a while was sending us these things
because they can't do anything about it
and they know that it's a problem and
they've reserved this
year and they um and said that they'd
really like to help with us if we pass
it but you know as you know you know I'm
not saying anything new to you that when
if I had a grievance
against uh my town mhm which for all
tense of purposes that's what a condo
association is it's it's a town a town
and if I have a grievance you know the
the end result is if I can either run
for office and and knock somebody out
and if I can't win if I can't convince
my constitu other neighbors that you
know that that um we have a problem and
they elect those bad apples the only
resolution I have is to move out of
town yeah and you've got enough money to
do it uh that's
maybe woman who was in talking 10 times
10 but if I have enough money I probably
would win the election because I you
know yeah I spend enough money to win
right so however yeah how how do we how
do we reconcile the difference how do we
reconcile that at the end of the day
that yes if you have a if the town is
violating some laws you take them to
Superior Court it's the same deal and
and I hear you about finding lawyers who
willing to take the case and I assume
the why most lawyers don't want to take
the case is because they've always
lost you know that the end of the day
when you go to Superior Court the court
is going to favor you know the the
system well that's an interesting
question since didario was claiming that
the court favors the individual unit
owner that comes before them I never
heard that before right by the way I've
called up uh managed to talk with five
of the people on that list of eight that
he gave you and um the big law firms
totally I'm not including them because
they they totally say that they have no
idea they don't know anything about cond
La they don't they don't know anything
about anybody there that works with
condo LA but they may may have taken a
case at some point they don't
know probably the other side one of them
told me that she um what you guys want
to do the
vot whatever you
[Laughter]
want like say IDE do you want will to
say
okay do you want to say something will
oh I'm sorry you were hiding over there
I didn't think you wanted to say I was
trying to drag you into the
conversation by the way did I give you
this latest
Amendment
sorry so you well you live in a condo
right no I live in a residential home I
just own a few and have own a few over
the years and you rent them no you own
them so my name is he probably got more
money than
me no nobody my name is will infantine
I'm the chairman of the labor committee
and for some reason the speaker is angry
with me and made me the uh chairman of
the condo and homeowners association or
board committee thing
there over the years I have come and
testify in front of the Commerce
Committee a number of times and I have
been opposed to uh this um dispute
resolution board because I didn't think
it had any teeth and the numbers didn't
quite quite match up who was going to do
it what was the fee going to be and some
of these other things so sitting on this
committee I I don't want to say I'm I've
softened a bit but I've listened to some
things that are kind of disturbing I
have sat on four or five different
condominium boards over the years
difficult things uh million dooll fires
and all kinds of other stuff where I cut
my teeth and learned everything about U
condo law and and condo
documents um without question there are
people that will never be happy with
anything they'll never be happy with
their neighbors their Association the
color of flowers that were planted in
the spring so the concern was that
people are who are um antagonists are
just going to overrun this committee uh
or this dispute resolution board with a
bunch of of things that are just
nonsensical but there have been some
things that we have heard that shouldn't
be going
on uh heavy-handedness by property
managers not providing um standard
documents you know you want to look at
the plowing contract or the landscape
contract and and that the board approves
you know it's supposed to be transparent
you're supposed to see these things
minutes that don't come out for 6 months
at a time
um uh not having elections arguing about
proxies and and you know I've seen it
all uh and and now i' I've
um had testimony to some of these things
so I would like to find an appropriate
mechanism uh having not seen really the
the the amendment wanting to go through
some of these
things um
the attorney General doesn't want to
deal with it Mr chairman I I know your
opinion if you don't like it leave or
get on the board and fix it which is
what I did a number of times um so I I
wish there was a a better mechanism I
think each time representative Aly
brings something it gets better and
better um
I I think I would having not really
looked at this and massage this thing
she was correct she was throwing a she
was she was throwing a big curveball
with oplc this year to no fault of her
own um this last uh month
um with with this ridiculous
expense
I don't like one of the things I heard
but again it's it's it's it's something
that can be worked out I don't have the
perfect answer there is definitely there
are definitely a few issues are are they
Monumental are we going to have hundreds
of people come into the to this dispute
resolution uh probably not are there a
couple that are going to hold some
people's feet to the fire yes does it
have the teeth it really needs probably
not um and um would I like to see a
sunset just in case it doesn't work
yes um so um I know I just threw you a
whole bunch of non-committal
stuff but there are some things out
there that need to be dealt with and I'm
not sure how to handle them I move that
we uh interim study of this bill
Amendment so instead of of doing it next
week again you
yeah I
thought
um it was going to finance because
oplc had submitted
$380,000 yeah it would still go to it
would still go to
finance and at this point it wouldn't
but yeah oh and there are
some